Joe Biden was caught with confidential
documents again yeah seriously for the
second time more confidential documents
I guess the only thing we can do is have
the FBI rate his house and arrest him
it's kind of funny that we do this story
and then like in the middle of the day
AIDS find more confidential documents
just making things worse there's one
article that said that this was a
massive political gift for Donald Trump
so sure I guess here we go and I'm kind
of frustrated by it because it's just
like yeah yeah we get it but we are
seeing some action from the Republicans
in terms of act the house Adam Schiff is
Furious saying that they're inquiry into
January the January 6 committee is to
defend Donald Trump and protect
themselves blah blah blah but we'll talk
about all that plus we got some other
news the FAA shut down all flights this
morning because the no Tam system went
down from like six to nine a.m that's
shocking because it hasn't happened
since 9 11. but the crazier thing about
it to me was that the FAA said notice to
all of our stakeholders
stakeholder is a world economic Forum
term we recently heard when Mia the
musician got canceled from I think it's
called Field Day in London they said
your presence would be offensive to our
stakeholders or something that effect
you can see the language is spreading
that's the intent you will own nothing
and you will be happy so we'll talk
about that plus the bud Administration
wants to ban gas stoves they're walking
this back after a major backlash but not
before AOC actively defended it because
she's claiming that using a gas stove
makes you stupider it reduces your
cognitive abilities I mean maybe that's
true but I don't believe these people
they want to get rid of your gas stove
for climate change and all that stuff so
we'll get into that but before we do my
friends head over to
surfinginternetsafe.com and pick up
virtual Shield a virtual private network
service you simply download it click go
and it protects you as you browse the
web you can get 78 off for Life 8.33
cents per month plus a 30-day free trial
head over to surfinginternetsafe.com
they say their VPN service is compatible
with all devices and allows you to
browse the web safely securely and
anonymously using their Global Network
of servers and private IPS virtual
Shield lets you browse the web
completely anonymously so the big name
isps and other third parties will not be
able to Monitor and sell your internet
activity
when using their VPN service your
traffic is routed through their secure
and encrypted servers this means that
any restrictions censorship or blocks on
your internet are bypassed completely
free for 30 days available on Mac
Windows iPhone iPad Android and chrome
it does all the work for you all you got
to do is download press the button
you're encrypted it routes all your
internet through an advanced encrypted
servers this actually means that your
Wi-Fi connection will also be secured as
you're going between your your data
points your routers at home they got
personal family and business plans
available family plan includes 15
devices business plan allows you to add
as many as you want I'll hide your IP
fight sensorship military grade
encryption head over to
surfinginternetsafe.com pick up virtual
Shield shout out they have supported
this show from the beginning they've
supported my other YouTube channel from
the beginning we're big fans thank you
so much for sponsoring the show and
don't forget to head over to timcast.com
become a member support our work by
clicking that join us button at
timcast.com you'll get access to
uncensored segments from the timcast IRL
podcast but you will also and that'll be
up tonight at 11 but you will also be
supporting our cultural and cultural
Endeavors we're opening a skateboard
shop a coffee shop it's multiple floors
and probably a private club now we're
thinking about this we're talking about
the other night maybe a private club up
top
for like a certain degree of you know
members and and we're gonna figure that
one out but um in terms of the cultural
Endeavors I just want to say one thing
this Saturday at DC's Freedom Plaza I
will be there skating and we're bringing
a big old crew Phil Labonte If All That
Remains is going to come hang out so
we're going to jam and play some music
and just chill I'll be skating our skate
crew will be coming with us apparently
there's a bunch of people who watch the
show who've already said they're on
their way they're going to come hang out
I'm really excited for that and I just
want to address you know someone on the
slap forums making the claim that I
showed up last Saturday that everyone
skated on the other side of the park and
that I couldn't do a shove it and those
are offensive lies first of all no one
said or did anything no one said
anything to me and I was sitting next to
everybody and not only did I do a shove
it first try I did a gazelle I did a
Nolly gazelle so don't even come at me
bro I was doing Nolly half hard late
flips I was doing kickflip cancel flips
these people all they have are lies and
you know many of you may be saying I
know you're talking about let me just
tell you this what these woke people are
doing is trying to lie and claim oh Tim
was just there goofing off and he's bad
at skateboarding ignore it now we're
showing up Saturday I'm gonna do some
switch tray flips maybe a nollie flip
crook nollie flip out and I'll shut up
all the haters okay I haven't I haven't
been skating that much I'm probably not
gonna flip not only correct but you know
I did a gazelle I'll do uh I'll do some
nollie hard flip blade flips or
something if you don't know what that
means fine don't worry about it just
come hang out on Saturday in DC's
Freedom Plaza and bring your friends
we're gonna give away a whole bunch of
boards and it's going to be a lot of fun
joining us tonight to talk about not so
much that but everything else is Jamie
uh Michelle Michelle I almost said it
wrong that's why I pause everybody does
I'm used to it but I really I mean I I
really appreciate it when someone gets
it right so rare but hi uh who are you
what do you do uh I'm the founder of
gays against groomers an organization
that started up a little over six months
ago uh to fight the sexualization
indoctrination and medicalization of
children being done in the name of
lgbtqia Plus plus plus plus
um but yeah I'm the founder of that the
president and I'm really excited to be
here with you to talk about all things
that and other things so gays against
rumors actually it's LGBT people it is
more concerned about what's happening
with kids yeah everybody in the
organization is LGB or t we have a few
trans people we also have a created a
sub Coalition partner Coalition uh
called trans against groomers because so
many trans people were reaching out
wanting to help
um and yeah so the whole organization is
comprised of us
um fighting it from inside the community
because that was seriously lacking you
know a lot of us were speaking out
against it individually but there wasn't
a unified Force basically yeah I I was
told you were going to bust that book
out somebody let me know because Ian
bought genderqueer it's a big problem
it's a huge problem we definitely got to
talk about it yeah we should talk about
that yeah for sure it's terrible but
yeah it's just a bunch of us from within
the community uh we were launching
chapters every day we I think we have
like 20 now
um we have our first International one
in the UK so yeah things are growing
very quickly I wasn't expecting it to
grow as fast as it did to explode onto
the scene but
um you know I think that just goes to
show how needed voices from inside the
community were fighting this because
it's giving us a bad name too I mean we
have skin in this game
um because the majority of us oppose
what's being done but they are
associating all of us with it and it's
you know it's hurting the kids immensely
I mean it's destroying them but it's
also hurting us and so we needed to put
our voices out there and do something
about it I mean it's ours it's our must
to clean up and we're here to do that
right on well thanks for joining us
should be fun we also got Luke hanging
out hey guys my name is we are
change.org I hope you guys are enjoying
your new normal or as it really is a new
world order and if you don't know what
that means you're not paying attention
to help spread awareness about what's
really going on there you could get this
shirt on thebestpoliticalshorts.com
because you do that's why I am here
thank you again so much for having me
well thank you Luke for coming and
everyone hello hi Jamie and last night
we talked about Vapes and I we may have
been actually distributing some fake
info or unresearched claims about the
dangers of Vape vitamin E acetate in THC
Vapes or in a nicotine Vapes when they
were actually in the THC Vapes a lot of
the problems coming from Black Market
Vapes in general not the idea of vaping
although we talk talked about moderation
people hitting the thing 500 times a day
might also be a problem maybe we'll get
into that later I just want to put that
out there that that is on my radar
research and I've talked to Luke about
it also thanks for bringing that up and
uh let's let's move this along Serge
tell me yeah what's up guys served.com
as always all right here's the first
story from the hill second batch of
classified Biden documents found at new
location a second batch of classified
documents belonging to President Biden
was reportedly discovered by White House
aides days after discovery of public
documents from a former private office
the new batch was found in a separate
location from the first
okay I just you know part of me was like
why even bother reporting this at this
point we get it the Democrats do these
things over and over again Joe Biden as
vice president had no powers to
declassify anything nor did Hillary
Clinton as Secretary of State but Donald
Trump should either go to jail or be
ineligible for public office because
they found classified documents at his
house but when it comes to Joe Biden
it's uh it's no big deal he's
cooperating it's whatever why why would
they report why would the White House
report this about Biden are they trying
to get out ahead on something or create
like a thing that oh it turned out it
wasn't that bad now everything can be
put to rest or Biden came to him as like
you know we can't really ban gas stoves
and then the real powers that be yes we
can we're gonna get you in trouble look
at all the documents you left document
the the poor the poor guy's forgetful so
uh I don't think he even knows what's
going on here but he was confused even a
few days ago uh mixing up a uniformed
Salvation Army member for a secret
service agent specifically talking about
all the great things and all the great
times he had with the Secret Service so
I mean the guy's not there he's not
really up there now the documents that
were found originally were related to
Intel related to of course Ukraine Iran
the United Kingdom he of course was a
vice president this this is all
happening a few years ago this this
release actually was caught the day
before the mid to term elections that of
course was the second release I don't
know I'm talking about the first release
that's happening right now
um and the the office that it was found
was related to a think tank that was
also allegedly connected to a lot of
money coming in from China so a lot of
questions surrounding uh those first
documents that were CL you know
classified that were founded in that
private office what are these documents
related to we don't know yet uh I think
we're only going to find out a few days
from now but again they are classified
so I wonder if what I wonder if what
we're actually going to be finding out
is going going to be relevant to anyone
so in Peach Joe Biden yeah impeach
everybody have an impeachment party
Biden says he was unaware of uh Which
documents were found which ones were
found yeah I know I don't even know what
I was taking illegally okay that's the
defense that's the thing though about a
president leaves office they've got all
these AIDS moving boxes of paperwork
this and that if like six papers with
like confidential things that are like
don't tell the guy's last name in The
foodie ate like oh who cares so what if
it was like State secrets and it's like
blatantly destroying our national
security for some reason now I
understand but like dude just you can
classify almost anything as the
president so like what but he was the
vice president when yeah he's not
allowed to do that yeah he's not allowed
to declassify documents as the vice
president I'm curious James to your
thoughts I know like your organization
is is very very focused on one issue
right but you but you aren't just like
you're you're conservative I'm a
conservative I'm I'm right-wing yes so I
mean I mean I I I know
oh my God no
offended that that could even possibly
be up for question now I'm basically
with Luke here where the guy has no idea
like what he's doing
um I mean I don't know how long he's
been suffering from such severe dementia
but uh I think it's been a while I don't
think back then he was though but um you
know we don't know what the documents
are exactly but I think that you know
it's telling that the left seems to not
give a single crap about the issue you
know they're running cover for him when
you know they were trying to prosecute
Trump for the same thing he made a good
point you said that you you didn't think
his brain like how did you say that back
then his brain wasn't as broken not as
broken I feel like it was pretty broken
no but hold on but hold on in terms of
like dementia you know yeah and Ian just
said that Biden didn't know he knew back
then yeah I understand him not knowing
now yeah now he doesn't know I mean he
doesn't know where he is he walked up to
a Salvation Army guy and was like I
spent a lot of time with the Secret
Service and the Salvation Army guys
wearing it says Salvation Army on his
chest and he's just like what's
happening honestly I live for these
moments with Joe Biden like they give me
so much entertainment and and honestly
it's just you know you have to laugh at
the state of things otherwise you're
going to be very very depressed every
single day so yeah humor and human you
know it's a basic part of what we do as
human can we even be human without humor
but that you know laughing at this
sometimes it feels like riding the the
nuclear bomb down you know doing the
Yeehaw thing like like in was that Dr
Strange lover yeah yeah at the end of
strange love but this leaves me with the
question is he just an old man with
dementia is he a puppet or is he a
criminal mastermind selling secrets to
China so they give him lucrative
contracts to his son what's going on
here what do you think is going on here
what's your take on what if what if
Hunter is weakened at Bernie Zing his
dad I mean I think think he initially
started as you know he he was not always
a very um mentally incapacitated man
um I think he has had deals with China
going on for a long time I think now he
doesn't know what deal is what or what
exists and what doesn't
um maybe a little I don't know I think
they pump him full of a lot of meds that
that give him a little bit of um Clarity
for moments in time
um but I think he definitely knew what
was going on when these deals were
originally created
um and I'm sure he knows about them now
but you know doesn't really doesn't
really focus on it too much to
to know much about it anymore what are
you think Ian um puppet Mastermind
certainly a puppet of a greater scheme I
was thinking last night about the world
in general and like most of the world is
sex trafficking murder bribery
destruction uh prostitution slavery kind
of thing like that's most of the world
we happen to be in this like Ivory Tower
of the United States where we have kind
of LED ourselves to believe that's not
the way things are and that when it
comes up and when we see it it's like an
aberration of the reality but the
reality is like kids are being
trafficked it's the largest business on
Earth it's human trafficking I'm pretty
sure
um and so that that government I was
like picturing talking to Obama about
he's like yo I have no I mean there's
people I don't know who's running the
show I don't know they it's definitely
not him no and he's not him I think he
would be straight up I think a lot of
past presidents if you get them to be
straight up will be like dude we are
such a small part of what's going on in
the world even though we think we have
the best military
um so I think Biden's a puppet long
story short I think they're being
controlled by Big Money the liberal
economic order the bank for
international settlements deciding where
the money goes that the Federal Reserve
is even going to give the US government
money and so we're kind of beholding to
the stakeholders in that sense uh or at
least we think we are stakeholders I
wouldn't even say he's a puppet at this
point I think he's just like a a little
figurehead just just you know that sits
there in the chair in the Oval Office
and and goes to these things but you
know everything he says is completely
you know in his ear at all times he
doesn't know what he's doing
um but he just I think is just kind of
put there for show but yeah all
presidents really uh you know they
always have people behind the the scenes
it feels like aliens took the country
over and then just like placed Biden
there yeah because Bernie Sanders was
going to win in 2020. he was dominating
that I don't know that has to do with
aliens Ian well all of a sudden like
seven eight weeks after the Bernie had
been running or four weeks or something
all of a sudden Biden is running now he
didn't even mention running for
president president for four years
before that someone picked him and put
him there I mean that's mine it's
surprising to me that that's you know
out of all the people that they could
have picked the Democrats could have
picked like they went with this senile
old man but it's because he's the
sacrificial lamb right their attitude is
whoever we put in place for this this
next term is going to be hated by
everybody because there's so much bad
stuff going on yeah they know he's not
going to sell him out either why waste a
Buddha judge you know Buddha judge has
got his whole life out of him it's like
Joe Biden's on his way out so they're
like hey it's you know you know it's
like you know when you go to a grocery
store and you're looking at the milk the
milk right up front by the glass expires
in like three days but if you go in the
back it like it'll last another decision
which one do you take well you take the
one in the back now I'm not buying the
milk it's gonna expire in three days
that's like buying that's like voting
for Joe Biden and going in the back is
that is the santis and and going to your
local farm and getting raw milk is a
form of Anarchy which I think more
people should do more than ever no but
even Biden himself would say that he's
like a bridge he's like a bridge
president to go from like this one air
to another and so he even knows his
place like in this you know and I don't
know if he's going to run again he's
already campaigning I guess but it's
like do does his own party even want him
to run again Joe Biden will never run
again he's too old I made that joke
twice I think he's going to try it maybe
he'll run I hope he's got physical
health
that's what I'm saying I think they
inject him with stuff right before he's
going to be his IV oh yeah he held up
his hands and you could track mark track
marks yeah no they they pump that man
full of uh plenty of goofballs yeah
they put him in as a placeholder knowing
he won't Squawk on the liberal economic
order because his son is so deeply
involved with barisman with China and he
himself has been so involved with it
dude he was stealing is this considered
stealing classified documents if you
walk out of there as the vice president
and take them well the the reason why
you know Biden is a perfect puppet is
because there's so much dirt on him he's
known as being one of the sleaziest
politicians in Washington DC he's been
in there for decades and he's known as
the the the politician for the lobbyist
even Barack Obama warned specifically
hey if if Biden ever becomes in power
the lobbyist will have a lot of control
over Washington DC now I'm paraphrasing
here I don't remember the exact words
but I remember talking about this a few
years ago where even Barack Obama was
worried about the special interests that
were involved with Biden and when you're
in DC for so long when you're in that
private club when you go to a lot of
these private meetings and get-ups and
islands and whatever it may be there is
so much dirt on you there is so much bad
things that you have done there's so
much room ample opportunities for
corrupted deals to go through and it's
pretty clear whether it's China whether
it's Ukraine whether it's even Russia a
lot of money exchanged hands especially
with his family so to think that he uh
is is is you know doing you know
something that's great I I think his
dementia I think his his cognitive
abilities are used as a distraction for
who he really is the larger swap monster
that isn't really in charge but is a
conduit for the real people who are in
charge yeah his I mean if you want to go
personal on the guy you got to look at
Tara Reid because her allegations
against him and what he did to her in I
don't know if it was the Capitol
Building or one of those buildings there
uh was is pretty grotesque I mean she
says that he's sexually assaulted her
and she's very graphic about what he did
to her up against the wall and then it's
like what he does and before he walked
away says you're she she rebuffed him
and he was like you're dead to me or
you're nothing you're nothing I think
this is a guy who's on camera sniffing
little girls and pinching and groping
them so it's like when you hear an
allegation it's kind of like oh you know
whose own daughter in her own diary
Ashley right wrote specifically how she
didn't she had to take showers at night
because she was afraid that he would
come in there freaking horrific
anecdotal horrific remember when he
broke his leg and he said the dog did it
yeah maybe he was trying to sneak in the
shower on like his granddaughter and
they decided to fight back
with the way things go down right that's
plausible you know again we don't have
any direct evidence of this we're kind
of speculating here but I think if you
look how Sinister and evil a lot of
these people are I I could see the
granddaughter just saying I I need to
practice martial law putting him in like
a martial law I'm sorry
uh what's the correct answer
practicing martial arts and then
snapping the leg of the person when you
when you imagine this you need to
imagine that it's it's very dark there's
a thunderstorm Biden's got a gigantic
grin as usual
all that facial work stay away I think
you're right Luke to not make the the
dementia like that it's the dimensions
of smoke screen for his behavior um like
Ronald Reagan I remember near the end of
his second term got them like
Alzheimer's I think they were saying
he's coming out with Alzheimer's but he
was also under investigation like
the concern that he had done some
illegal things I don't know the whole
story maybe you guys know more about it
didn't he think that Matthew Broderick
movie was real
that was a thing war games yeah yeah he
thought that was real he started
claiming that he didn't remember a lot
of stuff from his terms that's the thing
like Biden had you know when he
committed all these crimes and did all
this Shady stuff
um he didn't have dementia then I don't
think I mean you know now he does which
everybody can clearly see but there is a
this is a different Joe Biden in this
era that we're dealing with than like
who he used to be
um and he's been in politics for what
like 40 years he's been something like
that 50. has it really pretty sure it's
50 years yeah absolutely he's been in
there for for such a long time and he
looks uh pretty different especially
from the last few years there's a lot of
different photos of them earlobes you
can tell I mean I think he's he's gotten
a lot of plastic surgery too but also a
lot of the things just look totally
different on him than they ever did
before but I I'm calling it here I think
he's going to run he's going to win the
the next upcoming election and then the
third one and then the fourth one just
like FDR who was partly paralyzed and
still was able to of course successfully
be president of the United States for a
very long that was before the amendment
of course now it's term limits but like
hey that could be overturned during an
English national emergency vote for
Hunter Biden might as well right now
Biden fetterman I'm calling it it's
going to happen Hunter Hunter Biden is
kind of like the Anarchy vote in my
opinion because you're just like it all
comes crashing down if you vote for
someone like Hunter button I'd rather
vote for Kanye West than anybody else
sorry I love your name though we talked
about it before but I'd love to watch a
hunter Biden YouTube channel yeah it
would just be like like a live stream
just a 24-hour live stream I don't know
but not like a vlog him just being like
yo what up everybody Hunter Biden here
just scored some
crackers in the background kids and
grandkids of the Rockefeller like the
young Rockefellers young Rothschilds
young bidens to come out and tell the
world what really has been happening I
would love to see wouldn't that be
amazing if they did one day they just
like fig you know they just decided like
they're done with being these evil
people and they want to expose it all
same with the royal family the young
like Harry I got so much faith that he
and nobody thinks they're evil though
the Rothschilds and stuff like like pop
like no person like there are some
people like like I can't remember which
serial killer but there's like a serial
killer who was like yup I know what I'm
doing is it might have been Dahmer yeah
and he's like what I'm doing is wrong
and I know it and I should be locked up
but I can't stop but right but but when
you're taking you know human excrement
and blood and writing messages on the
wall trying to summon in demons I I
think that that crosses a different
level here of of what people actually
see and understand themselves people
doing it don't think that they are
either I think they're Heroes but or
they're entitled or something so you
were you were a question
yeah no I'm talking about like other
people how other people see the
Rothschilds and stuff like I and I feel
like you know maybe the kids of these
families like they're not kids anymore
now but like I don't know or their kids
you know the younger people in the
families that maybe don't feel the same
don't want to be part of the same cabal
like can see through it yeah I mean a
lot of them I don't know maybe one day
they'll decide to tell all a lot of them
are sociopaths so I I don't know if
sociopaths recognize that they are evil
um we would have to get someone who's
you know studied this topic to talk
about this specifically but when we look
at Washington DC it has the highest per
Capitol sociopaths than almost any
anywhere else in the United States and
there also is a theory that what Hunter
Biden is doing is trying to get some
sort of redemption against the father
who wasn't there for him or might have
potentially hurt him before and this is
Hunter Biden kind of releasing a lot of
this information getting it out there to
the general public on purpose that's one
of the theories out there in order to
hurt his father and and get some kind of
Justice let's let's jump to this next
story we have this from The Daily Mail
corrupt file and system reboot caused
all U.S flights to be grounded for the
first time since 9 11. no Tam system and
backup were both infected with corrupt
file as Pilots slam ridiculous decision
to ground planes I don't believe these
people I almost feel like when you get
AOC coming out calling for a green New
Deal saying we got to get rid of planes
and farting cows that when these people
ground every single plane in the country
and maybe it's political or ideological
now I don't know anything about that for
sure but I can't tell you this the FAA
verified on Twitter
tweet it out cleared update number two
for all stakeholders the FAA is still
working to fully restore blah blah you
get the point I noticed the word
stakeholders yes I know some people
mentioned that stakeholders been used in
certain contexts like this for some time
but in 2021 October the FAA announced
they'd be changing their language to be
more inclusive
they then start talking about how their
stakeholders blah blah blah
the world economic forum is pushing
what's called stakeholder capitalism the
idea is a shareholder is represented by
those who own shares State capitalism is
represented by the state and stakeholder
is better because it's everyone the
environment the neighbors the people
Downstream the people Upstream the
people on the other side of the planet
yeah basically sounds like communism oh
100 basically sounds like State
capitalism except for the planet instead
of an individual state where they're
basically like they they actually say
this on the there's a website called
Advanced ESG and they're like
basically saying that with a guiding
force stakeholder capitalism blah blah
blah this is why it's important so I
want to show you this one I know they're
different stories I talked about this
this morning but Mia the musician
mentioned that she got booted from a
concert the email says we have not take
the kick her out they say your tweets
are bad we have not taken this decision
lightly but we must consider the wider
risk risks to the festival and its
stakeholder others there's an important
connection between these stories
the phrase stakeholder did this this
concert that banned M.I.A call all of
their stakeholders doubtful did they
email the people who bought tickets who
are stakeholders did they even Define
who the stakeholders are exactly they
are what they're basically saying is
we're doing this for you we're doing all
of this for you so in the FAA is coming
out saying all the planes are shut down
everyone we're all in this together but
you know we're not because they're not
Consulting us they're not asking us what
we want they're telling us what they
want and they're using stakeholder as a
word to make you think you're part of it
but my friends that's like the chickens
thinking they work with me when I own
them the thing about shareholder
capitalism is that it's on contract if
you have a percentage of a company or
shares in a company you have a contract
to verify stakeholder is just it's
subjective like one day I could dump
trash up River and say everyone down
river is a stakeholder in my behavior
because they're all going to be affected
by it but then the next day I could say
no and I put a dam in there or a
shifting mechanism now those people
aren't stakeholders anymore because I
changed the way my system works so you
have no recourse as a stakeholder in
those systems is completely controlled
from the top I I highly warn against it
I think Klaus has taken us down or
attempting to take us down a very
dangerous road Cloud Schwab with his
world economic Forum stakeholder
capitalism and your item it is communism
it's a form of Communism all I know is
people
just having a bad week I had a few
months he's had all these disasters
happen and crises uh happen under you
know on his watch basically I mean what
it was like the Railroad Strike and then
the the shipping container issue and
wasn't there there was one other one
before this that like just happened he's
like went on vacation disappeared oh
yeah it was like import um not Puerto
Rico
look at me I can't remember I don't know
something like that there's been there's
been like four or five issues con
consecutively that just have you know he
hasn't um been dealing with that great
but that's what happens when you uh make
a diversity higher you hired the gay guy
just because he's gay right I mean he
really had no experience or
um accomplishments to really put him in
this position I don't necessarily think
it was a diversity high for Buddhism no
I think it's they're trying to tee him
up for a future political career and he
needed something Beyond just being I
guess I guess it's just really I mean
that that that job that position is just
a weird one I don't think but he's but
he says so it's like he doesn't even
qualify as diversity at this point he's
what says sits oh sis right oh says yeah
no that's when when when yeah see I got
you when uh when they were talking about
him like all the activists on Twitter
were like he doesn't count as LGBT
because he's a white man just being gay
isn't enough anymore especially being
white and gay no no that's very low
that's very long ranks now yeah he's not
a diversity hire I guess not you've
proved me wrong do you guys think that
the uh this FAA issue with the um the
computer program is a false flag and or
a computer virus that a foreign country
put in the system some many people spec
calculated my business might have been a
Cyber attack yeah the Biden
Administration said it wasn't I would
lean more towards their intentionally
crippling the economy and this had a
profound impact we were affected by this
we had people who needed to fly out for
work and we had a hiccup that delays us
which all need to understand about
economic Warfare let me tell you
something
China and the US they're both at War a
component of that war and a component of
every war is let's go all the way to the
beginning putting food in bellies the
saying goes that soldiers march on their
stomachs if you can't feed your soldiers
you lose the war that is to say you need
to find food and you need to be growing
that food there need to be people who
are working Farms otherwise there's no
war
so for someone like China or Russia or
anyone else at War
shutting down our capability of flight
means all this economic activity just
ceases and that means our ability to
develop Tech our ability to run our
businesses is diminished simply put it's
very similar to if you were at war with
someone thousands of years ago and you
set fire to all their Farms so they
couldn't feed their soldiers our planes
getting shut down may seem like well we
can't fly and have fun and go travel on
vacation but in reality it means with
tens of thousands or hundreds of
thousands of flights canceled business
is shutting down for days too because
it'll be people trying to catch up I
think when we talk about Insurrection
people say they March into the Capitol
building and stood there that they
destroyed or disrupted the government
maybe in part this is the kind of thing
that's an Insurrection if these were
American citizens that implanted a virus
like shutting down the electrical grid
the transportation system the food
supply though that's real Insurrection
in an economic Warfare State the fact
that they're using the world economic
Forum terminology just says to me like
outright I don't trust them because
these are the same people who are like
we should and be flying on planes planes
are bad but they they all fly on private
jets with their 5 000 Jets at the
climate like Summit exactly they don't
want you to have it because you're a
pleb but they should have it yeah
because well that's not fair well it's
bad for our stakeholders but me flying
on a private jet to do the work that I
do to save the world is good for our
stakeholders you see how that works yeah
they they consider that like you know a
benefit for the Earth because they're so
important and they're such Geniuses that
they're going to go solve it but they
need to take their private jet and and
cruise on their private yachts Mega
Yachts you know and it's all part of the
process you have to trust the process
and the science that's right that's
right yeah stakeholder capitalism is is
the future my friend it makes no sense I
don't understand I still don't
understand it it's communism you're not
supposed to understand it it's not
capitalism I'll tell you exactly what it
is it is Chinese style communism if you
read their website they say
that stakeholder capitalism takes into
consideration anyone impacted by a
business not just the shareholders and
the customers this allows free market
opportunities to flourish while still
being responsible and that's meaningless
you know this is this is about the
centralization of power very few people
have a lot of power they want all of it
they want more of it so what better way
to do it than to think of these new
buzzwords that of course amount to
anything and essentially what they're
building up to here some people have
called it the great reset some people
have called it the UN 2030 agenda some
people have called it the new world
order at the end of the day all of it
leads to is the massive centralization
of power for themselves Davos is about
to start next week and their theme for
next week is quote cooperation in a
fragmented world the list of attendees
was released and it's the FBI director
the CEOs of Amazon BlackRock Pfizer The
Gates Foundation the Solaris Network 52
heads of state 600 CEOs are going to be
meeting at one of the highest points in
all of Europe where they of course will
meet privately talk about a lot of
things publicly as well but at the end
of the day this is a list of of just
absolute lunatic criminals coming
together that are going to come together
in a way that benefits them and they're
going to think of more schemes more
buzzwords in order to convince you to
give up your power and authority to them
you know what this makes me think of is
the Bilderberg Group or the the
Bilderberg meetings remember that
whatever happened to those it is
I covered it last year and it was me and
my friend just uh Josh Friedman that
covered it and we were the only two
journalists there wow and you can still
see that coverage
um you know on my YouTube channel but no
one else I thought they like dropped off
and this was like their new gig but it's
still happening well there's there's
private meetings amongst other private
meetings there's smaller groups and
bigger groups and you know you know when
when you have so many powerful people
come together in one room when you have
the FBI director coming and meeting with
the heads of Pfizer there's a lot of
ability there for them to of course hey
say I'm going to give you this money in
this way you just kind of make sure you
weaponize the intelligence states to go
after our critics and to think that
that's not happening that these people
aren't colluding together and conspiring
together for their own personal benefit
is absolutely I mean that's the sole
purpose does anybody believe otherwise
truly well when when we look at these
meetings and we look at what these
people say especially yoel Roth Harari
they're coming on and saying there's
going to be you know a time very soon
where people are going to be useless
there's going to be a lot of people that
are going to need to adjust themselves
to live in virtual reality a lot of
individuals who won't have any meeting
who won't have any jobs who will be
absolutely meaningless in our world and
we won't need them so this is what
they're thinking about this is a part of
also their fourth Industrial Revolution
Klaus Schwab likes to talk about this as
well but essentially this is the larger
takeover of our life and our society for
the benefit of the very few you got a
couple names mixed up it's Yuval Noah
Harari yeah
yoel Roth is the Twitter guy
they look very similar by the way
similar names they look extremely so
thank you for that factor well he's a
fascinating guy sapiens the book and I
mean in a way they're talking about the
transhumanist you know Evolution and how
we're we are you know in a lot of ways
we're becoming cyborgs you know maybe
inevitably maybe
um so it I I think it's not like they're
completely wrong about everything in
Pure Evil like they're just trying to
find a way to make things not go to
World War III but I don't agree where
did you get that
there's a thing called order out of
chaos they sow the chaos in order to
yeah they create the problem in order to
create the solution which benefits them
that that's that's their kind of code
book that they've been working from for
a very long time because you look at a
lot of our problems that Humanity deals
with these problems are usually
engineered from a top level and done in
a way where of course people will
Galvanize towards them asking them to
please stop or only when they give up
their money or their rights does it stop
and then it never does stop it's just a
larger con game that people keep playing
into
um that's screwing them over yeah I
thought 911 was like that just whip
people up into a frenzy got them all to
go to war in the Middle East for weapons
that didn't exist and then so you think
the next one's aliens or something I
mean the pandemic is a great example too
I mean they they
manufacture this fear you know by the
indoctrination they honestly groom
Society with this big Pharma groom them
and and all of their cohorts but to make
them basically beg for a vaccine to open
back up you know to give them their
lives what Trump was the one who who
spent the operation warship was all him
don't get me started they engineered
they engineered a lot of things uh
exactly but like but then they come in
with their their solutions to the
problems they create like if kovid
wasn't put on TV and just blasted
everywhere 24 7 for like a year and a
half two years people would not think
anything of it they'd think it they were
getting a cold they're like you know a
flu or whatever I think it was
substantially worse than that no I'm not
saying it's just the common cause I'll
tell you from what I've talked to people
and from my experience I don't know did
you get covered I did but the what we
had yeah it felt like something strange
okay no I I had it and so did my fiance
we had it at the same time and it
presented in me as a horrible headache
like I feel like my head was smashed in
with like an ax you know I mean just the
the excruciating pain it was mostly that
for me and and it felt very much like a
flu besides that like it was like an
extreme flu for me but I I know that
obviously I know it has killed people I
noticed put people in hospitals I'm not
saying it was nothing I'm just saying
like I feel like if it wasn't so
manufactured like the media
um spotlighting it and just you know
running the numbers 24 7. like I don't
think people would have thought it was
some massive pandemic like Global
pandemic I think they would have thought
I was going around you know that was not
good but I don't you know now like they
half agree okay fair enough it was so
bad for me that I actually had to stop
working really and that's like that
never happened and I actually called the
hospital okay early variant like yeah so
I I was like I was ready to go and get
put in a hospital bed that's how bad it
was no I was basically hyperventilating
my temperature dropped by like eight
degrees and then I did the only thing a
smart person would do is I call Joe
Rogan yeah you have to
help please no but I called the hospital
and they were like good luck and then I
was like okay and I was like I guess
I'll just I'll probably be fine because
I know all the data and everything yeah
and that that as it was getting late it
was so intensely bad I was like if this
doesn't Peak here I will be in the
hospital on a ventilator you're very
lucky you didn't go to the hospital
because a lot of people that did were
put on certain drugs and put down uh put
on ventilators that gave them organ
failure yeah I called Joe Joe talked to
me I ended up calling a private doctor
private doctor gave me a prescription
cured me overnight isn't that amazing
monoclonal antibodies and and that's the
thing like they the the government the
media whoever the Puppet Masters they
didn't want you to have Ivermectin or
whatever you know these things are that
would clear it up very fast instead you
don't think so but they like banned
discussing it what you don't think that
they want it they you think they wanted
us to have it I have I I no I think they
I think they didn't want you to have it
but I don't think Ivermectin does
anything
well there's a new study that just came
out that that well whatever Joe Rogan
whatever you're talking about anything
besides an outright told me to get
monoclonal antibody okay I didn't I
didn't take the evermectin because I
didn't want it right and then my the
doctor made me take it several days
later when I was already better and then
The Daily Beast smeared me claiming that
I was the poster boy for Ivermectin when
I was like I didn't even want it right
no so I had a different experience I was
you know prophylactically taking it and
I had a totally different experience
than a lot of other people do and there
now there's a new study that came out
specifically with that uh with
Ivermectin highlighting a lot of very
surprising findings especially if
there's early treatment that actually
did support a lot of help for a lot of
individuals and a lot of people but
again we're not medical doctors we're
not here giving you any kind of medical
advice uh but it wasn't just that it was
also the antibodies that the government
went after and tried to deny to the
American people as the federal
government was saying hey Florida is
having a lot of success with this
Florida give us all of your antibody
treatments right now and Floyd Florida
luckily was one of the few states that
said no we're going to keep giving it
out and this is why Florida had such a
success compared to of course New York
and Michigan where they took sick people
and put them in nursing homes yeah I
don't like the censorship but I don't
like the tribal I'll agree with
something because the other side said it
no no so like when when I was going
through all the Ivermectin data and I
was like eh I don't know what we see
here you've got one side saying no one's
allowed to talk about it another side
saying it's a miracle cure and I think
neither are true I just want to be clear
I think you should be able to talk about
it but I don't think it's a miracle I
wasn't like pushing just Ivermectin like
I I don't care about it Ivermectin I was
just saying in general all the other
things that were available to help
people feel better and get better were
suppressed
um completely silenced de-platformed if
you brought him up because I'm like back
to the uh subject of you know creating
chaos to bring order like their desired
order was the vaccine and you know so
they suppressed all of these other
things that were actually helping people
to bring the vaccine which is you know
the order they created out of their
chaos including early treatment the big
one was monoclonal antibodies the body
Administration was trying to stop that
when we when it was an FDA approved
treatment when we knew that it worked
when it for for those of us that got
sick here within like six maybe like
eight to ten hours of me getting it I
was better yeah and I and I told you how
bad I had it that night I just like it
was like 4am and I was just like that's
amazing like everything and they did
stop it the federal government said you
can't you have to stop using this
because there's allegedly a new strain
it was still helping some people that
were dealing with the old strain but the
federal government said no no no no
we're stopping the use of antibodies and
a lot of States had to stop it they also
made sure and prevented any kind of
early treatment which as we know now was
key to of course helping people not deal
with severe covid they also made sure
that the post office was confiscating
packages of ivermectin even when doctors
were giving it out to their patients not
just for covet but for actual uh
parasite infections that people had
people worked at night medications
because of this as the Rolling Stones
was writing fake hit news pieces about
ER being overwhelmed with people taking
too much Ivermectin which never ever
happened uh now there's a lot of new
studies there's a lot of new data and
again early treatment early use of of
that stuff is showing in these latest
studies is having a tremendous effect
and is helping people the government
never wanted to help you they wanted you
to be as weak as sick as you possibly
could so you would need them and you
would buy a product from their friends
exactly
the hardest thing to figure out about
all of this is that the data is wild
across the board and correlation is not
causation so we look at Sweden and
people say stuff like they didn't lock
down or they didn't mask or things like
that but they're also a population of 8
million people in relatively sparse
population settings in a relatively cold
environment which is very very different
from say Florida Which is higher
population density in a very warm
environment so looking at data across
the board from State like those two
places it's hard to actually figure it
out if you're looking at New York or
you're looking at California or Africa
right specifically with other countries
like Singapore or Israel Israel so my
issue is I think everybody's lying about
everything I think I think it's all
political I I get frustrated by all of
it because I desperately am trying to
sort out what's true and what isn't and
you get people saying pull into a
7-Eleven parking lot and get injected
from a stranger which is the stupidest
thing I ever heard but then you have
people coming out and asserting and I'm
going to say it again because I know
people are big on Ivermectin I'm like
dude I've looked at a lot of the data
there's some good data there's a lot of
bad data there's a lot of propaganda on
both sides and when I was like when I
was talking to Joe about it this is like
two years ago I said I'm not convinced
I've been looking at the debt I've been
desperately trying to find what people
are claiming to see and I think what it
is is a lot of people are just I believe
it and I'm like why Dude tell me why
show me a study there's I've I've gone
over like there's a website showing you
all these different studies and they're
like look at all these positive studies
and then I go through them and I'm like
okay this one is bad this one is good
this one is this one looks bad this one
looks stupid this one looks real CNN's
lying about it wapo's lying about
YouTube's Banning people who talk about
it but I'm still only seeing like
they're doing that they were doing this
thing of um
they were taking groups of studies and
then doing meta-analysis on all of them
and then I'm just like that's that's not
definitive then you had in uttar Pradesh
they were suggesting that one of the
reasons Ivermectin potentially showed
promise was that it was actually curing
people of parasites which then allowed
their immune systems and their guts to
work better and then when I said that to
Joe Joe just goes not to produce
inhibitor and I'm like Joe for what
reason are you saying this to me like no
offense like I liked you he's a smart
guy but like you just believing that
it's a protease inhibitor because
someone told you that doesn't convince
me when we're actually looking at people
who are actually being cured of worms by
this thing could it not be a proteus
inhibitor and a worm stunner it stuns
the worms and then your body kills them
I just there was also a lot of uh
preliminary data showing other uh
coronaviruses being affected uh uh by
Ivermectin this is why Ivermectin has
been talked about in So Many circles
even before it was called horse medicine
because it was found to have positive
effects in people that were dealing not
just with covid-19 but other previous
coronaviruses like uh I think it was
SARS and MERS out there and there was
some early data showing that it did help
with those specific viruses and there
are studies that shows that it didn't
and there are people who are like I
choose not to believe that study yeah
and then every time someone like says
like I saw a study that says this and
I'm like and I saw study it says it
doesn't see I'm going through all the
data man my gauge for that is basically
what's forcing forcibly censored what
can't you talk about like what is being
hidden and I am more inclined to then
want to learn more about that thing or
think that thing is good but I do agree
with you that like this whole uh you
know he said she said versus like you
know this person hates it so that means
it's great type thing that's exactly
what I'm talking I think it's really
dangerous and I think it's I I don't
agree with that way of thinking well it
seems very childish and and just not you
know based on anything reasonable except
for except for like a popularity contest
or like you know who you like more it's
just that that shouldn't help you how
people basically we got treatment they
gave us monoclonal antibodies yeah NAD
and a vitamin drip that night I fever
broke pain went away I'm at I woke up at
4 am and I was like wow that's it's like
it was crazy three days later the
prescription for Ivermectin the doctor
sent uh arrives and I said doc I don't
think I need it and the doctor said I
want you to take it anyway and I said I
am completely fine now this is amazing
and they said if it relapses or comes
back you're going to be mad you didn't
follow my instructions and I said fine
whatever you say Doc trust your doctor
but my issue is it's a it's exactly this
it gets censored and then people assume
because it censored it must be good and
that's not a good answer for me I don't
care what you guys believe if you guys
think I'm wrong you're allowed to do it
comment tell me I'm wrong all of that
stuff it's fine I sit here all day every
day and I'm reading the stuff and I have
people saying that I'm either naive or
ignorant and it's like bro the only
thing I do for for 12 hours a day is
just read constantly desperately trying
to figure out why people think these
things and what I've concluded is that
while there is some promising data
there's a ton of censorship which breeds
mistrust what I'm finding is that a lot
of this stuff is pure tribalism Donald
Trump recommended this therefore people
say it's good then they start censoring
it and I'm like I think people are he
didn't even recommend it he was talking
about possibility yeah
hydroxychloroquine specifically he was
talking about how hey there's some early
data here looking at this but Ivermectin
in a hole has been a breakthrough
medication that has helped so many
people deal with things like river
blindness and to have it just uh
relocated as horse medicine was after
absolutely crazy but the same people
that were disingenuously attacking it
were also trying to deny people antibody
uh help in New York white people were
told not to even try to get monocle
monoclonal antibodies uh because their
doctors have prioritized it for
non-white people yep they did the same
thing in Texas so these are crazy
individuals that know hey this is going
to help people but we're going to make
sure that we're not going to give it to
you because the way you were born this
is how our scientific Community our
medical community was being run that
that's no way to run anything any kind
of business any kind of institution
especially when it comes to people's
lives this was it was absolutely crazy
what was happening during covid
absolutely insane let's jump to this
next story because I've been sitting on
this one we got this from The Daily Mail
AOC says that gas stoves are linked to
reduced cognitive performance in spat
with Republican Ronnie Jackson after he
said he would never give his up you may
have heard the news the body
Administration wants to ban gas stoves
this is a psyop
sort of here's what happens the Biden
Administration consumer protection group
literally says on TV we want to
potentially ban gas stoves CNN in the
Washington Post then report definitively
they want to ban gas stoves huge
backlash ensues politicians and
personalities like AOC come out and say
well gas stoves are bad and there's
indoor pollution
then the backlash gets bigger and bigger
and bigger and they look really stupid
and they're pissing people off so they
issue a statement saying no no no no no
no we never wanted to ban gas stoves
you're all crazy Snopes then issues a
story does the Biden Administration want
to ban gas stoves false and now anybody
who claimed they did is going to look
stupid they're reversing someone posted
on Twitter it's a trial balloon they say
something and if the backlash is too big
they walk it back yeah same with the
invasion of Syria that's what Obama did
because people were like hell no we're
not going to war in Syria they didn't
invade they like to see how far they can
get or what they can get away with you
know or it's just they try to do it and
they were forced to pull back right so
it's like that story we talk about where
eBay had a yellow website and then
wanted to be white but then everybody
got mad when they changed it from yellow
to White so then they changed it back
and then every day they slowly
incremented the shade one degree and
then a year later the website was white
nobody cared really I think Cortez said
that they're gonna Alex AOC said that
they're gonna not ban gas stoves but
start only after 20 30 be creating
electric stoves from here on out and no
new apartments will have anything other
than electricity well many states have
already implemented a lot of these very
similar policies I think New York and
California already have it where if
you're building a building you cannot
have a gas stove inside of it so that
already is very disproportionately
attacking a lot of ethnic communities
especially that make their own food in
their own kind of specific way using a
fire in order to do so and when you use
electric this is this is going to mean
that we're going to of course use more
electricity which is going to hurt the
grid which California already is dealing
with a very serious problem with why are
they doing this are they trying to
deliberately destroy our our energy
sector yes yes also I like electric
better than gas I I like gas better
because you can pick up the pan and turn
it sideways and get heat all over the
pan to get a more even cook no you can
do that with electric no because if you
lift it up you lose the heat you can
turn it sideways and you can keep
touching it and the problem with uh it's
have you ever felt near the electricity
the problem with gas in my opinion is
that the fire moves and it creates an
uneven cook no matter what that's fun
that's the fun part you see that's
working with the fire see I like a
consistent stable even cook and you like
chaos I think that it's more consistent
with fire because you can get the sides
and stuff I like the chaos I'm what you
eat when my pan is on Full contact with
the electric that bacon Cooks perfectly
all around
I think for more Exquisite long-term
Cooks you want you want to be able to
mediate your temperature at will like in
a split second you want to go do that on
electric what are you talking about well
you got to go you want it 70 degrees
cooler than you want it 45 degrees
cooler over here and you want to I don't
think so because if you pick it up to
shake it around you lose the content
flat disc of heat that you can move in
any direction you want with fire the
fire is going all crazy and all over
that but you have no idea the point is
you got to maintain con physical contact
with the electric element because if you
lift it up no you don't yeah otherwise
even if you're working with like walks
right which a lot of people in the Asian
communities are you need a fire you
can't have an electric okay the problem
is people will use wood they'll end up
using dirtier things than gas if they
don't have access to Flame that's what
I'm concerned yeah yeah do you want good
Chinese food or crappy Chinese food I
want good Chinese food I will not walk
in there I want that Rice prepared nice
Ian makes a good point people in rural
areas without access to gas will start
burning wood yeah and that is so dirty
yeah that's what happened South Africa
man all the all the gas became uh I
don't remember the whole story but
basically using the fire and it depleted
all of the natural forests in the area
because they just used it to make fire
to warm their houses and the carbon is
going to put all that carbon yeah which
is terrible for your lungs and on top of
that if your power goes out and you have
an electric stove good luck getting some
heat to light a fire to warm yourself up
if it's in the middle of the winter at
least back in the day you had a gas
thing you could get the element on like
a candle on fire yeah for me this is
happening in order to push the kind of
digitization of everything to to fully
have a technocratic society you need
everyone dependent on technology and if
you're able to cut off that technology
you're able to control people more and
and cutting people's ability to heat
their own food by just simply clicking a
button that could be easily done with
this new policy and I think that's why
they're really doing it in my opinion
yeah I mean I personally prefer electric
but I don't want them to eliminate the
gas because of this reason exactly I
mean I really don't think we're far from
like a social credit score you know what
we see in China like and I really think
the the with the push for electric
everything electric cars especially
um you know and now this and everything
else oh you liked gays for groomers no
cooking friends oh your Tesla is also
going to be against groomers yes by the
way sorry
it's proper grooming goodness let's talk
about grooming well so no you know what
I tell groomers like actual pet groomers
that they should just refer to
themselves as pet stylists from now on
because if they if they ban gas stoves
Nationwide that means rural people won't
have access and a lot of those people
have gas tanks at their houses which
would put their cooking on the grid and
the grid can be controlled by external
forces yeah so it's it's just
centralization just like electric cars
you know I think yeah it'll never be
another reason I want to have that you
have a kill switch which a lot of
governments are working on especially in
Europe right now where they could just
turn off your car whenever they want to
that's so scary it's freakish dude yeah
I want to get a heating element on my
phone on the new Android model where I
can like a cigarette lighter push a
button and it'll heat up oh they have
those I'm pretty sure oh good yeah oh
yeah yeah I think they have this I think
I saw that get me off the grid of course
they can shut my phone off if they
wanted that's why they track you Ian
with the cell phone but you can also get
solar the problem with solar systems is
they're also hooked to the grid yeah so
if this system like if anything did
happen where they're trying to control
every everything you'd have to create
your own electrical grid like small one
off the grid like we have the we have
the van that has its own electrical
system I can I can plug into it without
having to worry about anything but even
our solar system which is like we
generate our own electricity with solar
panels we have to get permission from
the grid to activate can you plug the RV
into the grid as well as have it off
grid yes that's cool yes Shore power so
you can actually sync the battery up to
the grid if you want and that doesn't
you don't need permission for that you
just plug it in but like a big solar
system before we can even turn it on we
gotta the government has to come into an
inspection and all that stuff I know
methane's dirty I know that and you
don't want to breathe in direct methane
obviously you cook with a ventilation
system but I mean what's the the other
option is burning wood I mean that's the
reality of it is everybody's yelling at
me saying that gas is the way to go I'm
just saying when I'm cooking bacon I got
this nice even cook on the bacon it's
done super quick I don't gotta worry I
want to give a special shout out to Chef
Andrew gruel he's being extreme
extremely vocal about this and making
noise going on TV he was talking about
this on the show before this even became
an issue if you remember that time he
came on the broadcast it was a great
podcast you haven't listened to it check
it out uh how do you say his name again
uh Andrew gruel I believe how do you
spell it g-r-u-e-l yeah that was a great
podcast and he and he was warning about
that very specific issue and now now
it's here he's a professional chef yeah
he's awesome
and then he could and he cooked for us
oh that was great I enjoyed we have we
have an electric downstairs and I'm
always sad about it I'm always wishing I
had an open flame well I have another
flame we'll make a Brickwood oven yeah
at Freedom stand that's how you do it
we'll throw some wood in there and then
charcoal what a little natural wood you
go to the forest you'll get your own
wood get a little carbon there's
probably a bunch of trees that already
fell down you'll chop them up and you'll
do the work Ian I'm into it to convert
the energy I gotta get a really nice
chainsaw you ever use a chainsaw I
haven't but you know what this is a
random side note I used to be well not
long ago I was really into Bushcraft so
like this all sounds really fun to me I
never got into it but like I would watch
endless hours of Bushcraft videos on
YouTube it was like relaxing to me and I
was thinking like why am I so into this
and I think maybe my subconscious was
like to prepare you like you might need
these skills sometime in the near future
but no but that sounds fun to me I'd be
I'd be totally game for that I was
watching the island uh with what is it
Bear Grylls did you guys ever see that
show a couple years ago the island where
I don't know something that's called the
island where they go 12 14 people on an
island trying to survive men versus
women last night I was just a pouring
over episode after episode of it uh same
thing I've got this fascination with the
Survival Life although I'm
grateful for the things I have exactly
famous ones where they have the men and
women separate yeah that's that yeah the
men like within 10 minutes have like a
functioning Society that's how I fell
into it I was watching women are lost
walking around that's transphobic
there's numerous episodes of these shows
and it's like it's almost like there are
differences between the Sexes it's like
the guys have like a cabana and they're
like serving drinks yeah there was one I
watched I think it was Bear Grylls where
like the women kept going in circles
that's the one I watched last night and
they were crying for days yeah they
couldn't find their base camp so the
girls at the base camp were just like
they've abandoned them oh my God for
three to three twice or three times they
were going inside
but what got me there was I was watching
Andrew Tate's stuff about misogyny and
then they were like oh yeah our men and
women even is good at survival and then
I was like well let's watch this thing
so you watch some entertain content I've
been really diving deep on the entertain
stuff lately Destiny and um Pearl uh oh
yeah just Pearl just pearly things did
uh did a episode about it today that
came out did you guys I have like no
interest in the Andrew Tate Saga what do
you get what's your vibe from the
distance I mean I think he's a
you know piece of I don't know what if I
can I can't swear whatever I don't think
he's a good guy I don't like him I don't
like his method obviously you know I'm
anti-matrix you know his whole thing
with the Matrix which I think the way he
just markets that is very corny
um but you know there's I just feel bad
that these are this this is one of the
role models uh the most prominent role
models for like young men in our society
like I just think they deserve better
but um I'm not a fan personally and I
just I I don't keep up with the drama of
it right personally I'm with you I want
to like him because of some of the stuff
he said but right it just is well broken
you know yeah I agree with some of the
stuff he said I just I don't like him I
think he's a sleazy character
um obviously you know he's stringing
these young men along promising them
great things like to be to make
something great out of themselves and
honestly you know I I watched I did
watch one video kind of on his tenants
program or whatever like the Matrix I
don't even know what it's called but
like you join this program and he's
basically you know promising to to teach
you how to achieve Financial Freedom and
like own 10 Lamborghinis like him or
whatever and it's basically just like a
basic you know Shopify 101 course yeah
you know and like it teaches you drop
shipping which you could learn for free
on YouTube in like a day yeah so I don't
know I don't like people that take
advantage of you know people it's do you
think just you should be impressed and
wait for the evidence until you think
that oh definitely evidence wait for the
evidence I mean I think that in order to
hold him like he says that the Matrix is
against him I don't know I think that
you know I do remember he put out that
he he was on some podcast or whatever
and kind of primered it that like you
know they're coming after me just
because I'm so successful and I'm
breaking the Matrix and whatever so
they're gonna arrest me I think you
probably knew that something was coming
down the pipeline and so he put that out
as kind of like you know to set the
stage for it basically and like he
didn't do anything wrong because they're
just out to get him like he planted that
idea but I'm sure there is evidence like
I'm sure there is something but I am not
going to judge him until that's fully
known exactly I think he admitted to
most a lot of it which is like I don't
know if you would call what he did what
he admitted to sex trafficking I'm not
sure the exact definition of sex
trafficking but if you if you invite a
woman out to work for you uh and then or
you invite a woman out because because
she's in love with you and then she gets
there and you're like by the way why
don't you start doing this cam work for
me is that is that no that's not what it
is it's that you say I love you come
work with me we're going to do this
thing and then when she gets there
you're like if you don't do it I'm
kicking you out and taking your money
away forcing her into the position pull
the rug but but here's the issue I see
with Tate is because I've been looking
at a lot of stuff as well and some of it
I really do feel like you guys ever see
that movie
um the life of David Gale yeah I love
that movie it's really good that is such
an underrated movie Yes Kevin Spacey was
it was okay that's right that's right it
was so great in that all right so
basically what happens is this professor
is at a party he sees this uh this young
woman who got like expelled or something
and then she's like let's go in the
bathroom and hook up and then she says
like be rough with me and then he's like
Bangor and then she's like rip him off
rip off my panties and then he rips him
off and then she's like yeah yeah and
then she scratches him and he's like
yeah then she says he raped her ripped
her clothes off and she scratched him in
self-defense making it look like she
planned the whole thing so the reason I
brought that up is not that I'm saying
Andrew Tate is necessarily being falsely
accused but I'm wondering when you look
at a lot of these quotes and I'm like it
sounds like they were Kink playing when
he's like when he says things that are
so over like I was reading one quote
where it's like according to a
transcript he was saying like oh yes
baby I enjoy raping you this is so good
I was like this would actually sound
real man no it's a little incriminating
don't you say right right but like
there's that viral video where
apparently he's like beating a woman and
the woman said that they were just like
they're they were it was kink like she
wanted him to be rough and she was
totally into it but they what they do is
they take it out of context and they
make it seem like you shouldn't be
allowed to do those things now I'm not
trying to defend the guy saying he
didn't do these things I'm just saying
some of them are so over the top I have
to wonder if like he's just playing oh
if there's ever going to be false
allegations against Andrew Tate now is
the time for them to come out and well
some of the people what they're
suggesting is that one of the girls that
was working for him got really loud
mouth smashing stuff up kind of person
and then she went and kind of caused
this big scene and then other people
kind of piled on
um that's one suggestion but you know
well this has been an ongoing
investigation since April so we're gonna
see what the Romanian authorities kind
of put out there uh so far I mean we got
some text messages from Vice that were
you know allegedly reduplicated uh who
knows what the whole conversation was
really about what they only show oh
Andrew texting but not the responses
what was the response what was the
conversation I'm waiting to to find out
more before making any kind of judgment
calls but uh whatever people think both
scenarios could be true here it could be
you know the Matrix or whatever you call
it and he could be a bad guy it could be
both it could be one of them it could be
neither of them who knows uh let's wait
until we actually see the real evidence
let's jump to the story from Fox News
Harvard Medical School offers course
about health care for
lgbtqia plus infants the course promises
to focus on serving gender and sexual
minority people across the lifespan
what does that what does that mean an
lgbtqi infant preview bestant human
beings who haven't formed the ability to
speak have already formed sexual
identity is that what they're saying I
think that's what they're trying to say
yes I mean and this is coming from
Harvard this yeah this story we were
made aware of this story today and we
did a video on it one of our members did
a video on it it's just it's
I don't have the proper words to
describe it you know it's like
there is no red line how can they claim
that infants are lgbtqia but then also
claim it's it's social condition right
yeah that's an interesting one this
argument is that it's inherent within
all people
um which is it right I mean how how
okay so my thing is children uh that
includes infants and babies they cannot
they're they're they don't understand
what uh sexuality is you know they don't
they don't have these feelings so they
they cannot be
um any sexuality like they're just not
developmentally there yet and the fact
that babies are even being thrown into
this I mean it's almost like a mockery I
mean they just keep throw you know
making things worse and throwing more
and more at the wall and just I think
it's to shame everybody just a
humiliation ritual basically of like
this is what our country is turning it's
also for profit oh no that is the main
that is the main thing behind it all I
mean you know they the big Pharma and
all these hospitals with their gender
clinics they see they just see these
walking dollar signs I mean like to to
get a child hooked up into this system
um and get on these you know hormones
and puberty blockers and then eventually
the surgeries and what else the the
maintenance that that requires is a
lifetime I mean they are lifetime
patients and so when they get them young
I mean these are these are a million
dollars each maybe more than a million
dollars each throughout their lifetime
you know it's an ongoing thing until the
day they die they're going to be needing
these things to maintain it
um so I think that that is like the
number one motivator behind this entire
movement
um but yeah it's it's talk about loyal
customers oh yeah because you have to
keep buying the pillows you have to
because you're doing the procedures and
there's a lot of complications with them
I believe there's a monetary incentive
but I also think there's a larger kind
of deeper incentive when it comes to
breaking down the family unit and I
think there's even potentially even
bigger agenda when it comes to a
transhumanist agenda which of course is
also going to be very important with the
first fourth Industrial Revolution that
the world economic forum is pushing
where they want to have people that are
non-binary non-identified with their
actual sex and are just cyborgs of the
machine yeah I can see that for sure I
don't think that you know Pharma is the
only um motivator here but I think it's
a big one but yeah there's a bunch
there's others but Tim I see you holding
a did you read the book I haven't read
it I've seen enough you need to read it
I've seen pictures and nope I haven't
seen enough okay well I've seen enough
to know that it belongs nowhere near
children and you know like these uh
these people
um these activists these radical
activists that have hijacked our
movement and people that use our
community you know to like to push all
this stuff they're up in arms over book
Banning they call it book Banning and
it's like it's pornography in kids
schools and libraries like pornography
for kids should be banned like I'm sorry
what they you know they always try to
think education King oh
got it well that's that's it's so it's
like a lot of people on the right are
calling it porn and I'm like well some
of it yeah but I think it's more Kink
education which is which is worse it's
one thing for like an adult to be like I
am aroused and enjoy watching this it's
another thing if you have like a
curriculum where it's like here's how to
use an insertion device when I say
pornography like I don't mean you know
like it's literal pornography but you
know the writing it's suggesting I mean
it's sexual activities it it's uh in
great detail and exploring that
encouraging you know young children to
explore that within themselves the
reason I ask you if you read it because
we talked about this quite a bit the
other day the book is actually
very little about the weird sexual
explicit stuff and overtly about how her
parents were extremely abusive towards
her and she couldn't read till she was
12. she would pee in the yard she
smelled so bad the counselor had to pull
her out of class and tell her like
people are complaining about your stench
and she was wearing menstrual pads that
were so old they were crusted with blood
that was flaking off into her pants it's
no wonder she doesn't want to be a woman
oh right it's not it's not an issue of
like I feel a different way it's that
her parents were extremely abusive
towards her so we're talking about like
lgbtqia kids yeah no I don't I I think
they're totally wrong about this we were
talking to the Hodge twins and they were
saying that they thought that a lot of
this stuff is learned and I said I don't
think so and they said well if it's not
learned then how could you groom a kid
and I was like you can abuse and
traumatize a kid into doing all sorts of
crazy things you can get someone to
smoke cigarettes smoking cigarettes
isn't good for you right you can get
people to do things but what I was
saying is like if you take like humans
free of anything else and have them run
around once they grow up they will
figure out how to procreate if you
traumatize and abuse them you will cause
fear panic and and you know problems in
their future so they're talking about
lgbtqia kids
that's why I'm telling everybody to at
least you know figure out how to look at
the beginning of this book because
what's really showing is how these
people get traumatized and beaten into
being terrified of who they are hating
who they are I understand that like the
the thing in question in this book where
she's like is is getting the the
pleasure you know the adult act she says
she hates it and then the end says she
doesn't want to do any of this and is
asexual and doesn't want to be involved
and it's like yeah just absolute trauma
trauma and abuse and so what's happening
is these people who are traumatized want
to share that trauma with the Next
Generation and push it onto them I think
that's definitely part of it I think
that the people that are traumatized
though they they do want to do that I
think there's much more behind it though
too I mean
um
yeah I mean these this book is one of
many right that are just you know that
that cover this topic and other
inappropriate topics
um
but uh yeah and and in terms of grooming
kids I mean you can I I believe that you
are born gay like I I believe that
um you can be born gay and like nothing
happened to me as a kid nothing I know
so many gay people they had great
childhoods nothing you know a lot of
people say like oh you you were
traumatized or abused or whatever like a
myriad of different
um possibilities to clarify I'm
referring to someone who says I am not a
woman and I don't want to be romantic
with anybody it's like that feeling
right there is because her parents were
abusing her yeah no I know I'm getting
there I'm saying but uh you were saying
like um that
what did you say exactly you were saying
that like uh kids can't be you none of
this stuff can be learned or or um I'm
referring to like the non-binary gender
stuff yeah we're talking about like
lgbtqia plus infants or whatever I'm
saying that I agree with you like I
think people like I I think some people
are just gay some people yeah you know
but as far as like the non-binary and
when we're getting into like gender
ideology and gender identity I mean I
think that that can very very strongly
be manufactured and implanted in kids
heads and like even be seen as trendy
now which it is you know like um I have
um my fiance's sister uh she's in her
teens and
um she goes to school obviously and like
she's she was telling us how like it's
not even okay it's not even you're not
cool enough if you're just gay anymore
you know so these kids are this is just
being this culture being
um put into these schools and just into
into society you know through media and
everything that that it's very very
trendy and I think that I mean I think
that gender identity is definitely
something that can be manufactured and
to lead these kids into believing that
they were born in the wrong body because
they don't fit perfectly into like a
little binary stereotype box you know
well that's exactly it like this book
really outlines that and I think if
people are are trying to understand
what's causing people to experience this
look at what happens you get a little
girl her parents let her run around wild
in the yard peeing in the yard there's
like no supervision they don't even like
she couldn't read till she was 12.
that's a big one right there that's a
huge indicator of abuse oh yeah but she
draws a picture of a menstrual pad
crusted with black blood it's in the
first like the first portion of the book
and she's like I would wear these for
days with the blood flaking off like
coffee grounds and it's just like this
person isn't non-binary right they are
they are they they had a mother who
didn't tell her how to live and how to
be hygienic how to clean her body and
how to socialize so when she was
rejected by Society for being a a and I
mean this without like I'm not trying to
be mean but filthy literally and
unhygienic and and smelling like feces
she rejects it and says it's an issue of
being a woman no that's not being a
woman right being a woman isn't isn't
smelling bad and being made fun of and
insulted but she Associates those things
because
she's like you really read and it's like
she lives in the wilderness basically
and then when she tries to socialize
with normal kids she can't read and
communicate properly or socialize I've
heard of other stories about that like
where where these children are so abused
and neglected like I forget the name but
um you know she was locked in a basement
for like the first 12 years of her life
didn't know how to talk at all like knew
nothing and obviously you know that's
that's a rare case I mean maybe not so
rare I don't know but like that case in
terms of uh becoming
genderqueer or non-binary or whatever I
don't know I mean that's one reaction to
to this kind of abuse but yeah the fact
that yep but but you know there's a
saying that's like hurt people hurt
people right so like now this person is
writing her story and that's fine share
your story but it's one thing to write
it and get it out there and share it
with the world and then another to want
it in kids hands right you know like
even that that topic of just abuse like
I I truthfully I didn't know that was
all in that book like you know I've seen
um bits of it online but I I I've never
um well then and then with all that
abuse she writes about how she goes to
the queer straight Alliance and they're
all cheering for her and saying all
right they love her so imagine you smell
like crap you've got dried blood in your
pants for days your counselor is telling
you like you smell like crap something's
wrong with you you've got hairy legs the
girls are making fun of and you can't
read and you're peeing in the floor and
then someone comes and says I affirm you
you're okay and I love you all of a
sudden you feel good and you say please
I will do anything give me more of this
feeling right yeah that's a cycle of
that is the abuse that the person takes
on they start to rationalize as normal
and okay and it wasn't the abuse it was
the problem it was the gender or
whatever and then when they get older
and they're around kids they're like you
know what that abuse that I experienced
it is okay so if I do it to you there's
nothing wrong with that and then that
cycle you know you gotta accept like it
wasn't okay what your mom did to you
Maya that wasn't okay you should have
been ahead clean pants man you should
they should have been there for you
yeah that's a you know important issue
people who are you know abused uh
sometimes come out as abusers themselves
or they go the other direction and they
become Advocates against the abuse and
it could go either one of those two ways
depending on the human being depending
how they're raised uh but I I just kind
of want to ask you since you're kind of
looking into this uh you know a lot of
this is in our schools in our
entertainment and our social media I
mean this is going to have a lot of
long-term effects not only on the family
unit but of course on on everyone being
dependent on big Pharma everyone's
emotions and hormones being all
dysregulated uh what do you see here as
the end game how do how would you even
quantify why do you this is the question
why is this happening
yeah that's a big question
um like I touched on before I truly
think big Pharma is um one of the main
two motivators uh well maybe there are
more than two
um but big Pharma the profits obviously
um getting them hooked up to that system
I also think pedophilia is a huge
motivator behind it because I mean it's
not just about the transitioning of
children medically you know it's like
the whole thing it's the sexualization
the introducing them to sexual to sexual
um content and material and events with
the drag stuff
um you know having them now dance on
stage for dollar bills all of this I
think is definitely rooted in the
normalization of pedophilia I think that
that has been happening for a long time
that's been the goal for a long time and
you know back when when we were fighting
for just the right to get married and
and people would warn of the slippery
slope you know like well what's going to
come next pedophilia is next and I I
genuinely thought these people were
insane because all I wanted was the
right to marry and I was happy to pack
it up and go home after that and I think
we all should have gone home after that
like I don't know why these events are
still taking place when we have all of
our rights like we won the game go home
and now you know so I back then I
thought those people were absolutely
insane that rewarding of the slippery
slope but now we're here and I'm like
well they were right you know turns out
they were right and the push has always
been to normalize pedophilia with and I
think the end game here is to get a p
attached to our acronym our ever-growing
acronym
um there's a few peas already is there
yeah pan oh well it's not it's not in
the official acronym but yeah
I don't know I don't know I don't abide
by it none of us do we don't like that
but who makes the flag for that matter
you know it's a good question like I was
I was in Donald Frederick and I saw uh
uh it's it was the pride flag with the
black and brown on it and the trail ugly
and an eagle an eagle yeah I haven't
seen the eagle one I've seen the one
with the circle the yellow circle with
like a purple circle in it or something
I don't know what that means I don't
know what any of this means and then
another one just came out recently with
like do you remember like the Red
Umbrella yeah the pucker at anus what is
that it's it's a symbol of sex work
they call it an umbrella but you know
okay you know what it is it's a booty
hole Yeah it's a booty hole perfect I've
always been really
LGB is like its own to me yeah someone's
gay they're bi they're they're less
whatever lesbians are kind of gay so
it's almost like redundant but like
what's the difference just like it's a
label you say your name is it the way
you want is it what you want like what
makes you gay in your opinion wanting it
or the act and not wanting it at all but
having the act happen
um being gay is a I mean I'm
romantically attracted to women you know
I am physically attracted to women I
only want to be with women you know I
can I can appreciate if a man is
handsome or not but I feel nothing
towards them so it's being gay isn't an
act for me it's a feeling I mean it's
who I am like you know it's part of me
but at the same time I I cannot stand
people that make being gay or whatever
they are trans their entire identity you
know I look at being gay me being gay is
like the same as I have dark hair I'm
also gay you know I also like wearing
Adidas jackets I don't know it's just
something about me you know it's part of
me but it's not all of me it's not all
of who I am yeah do you find that scale
the Kinsey scale I was told my buddy in
college was a gay dude he was like oh
yeah everyone's on the Kinsey scale now
I'm finding out Alfred Kinsey was right
psychopath yeah that's funny trying to
sexualized people I went to Indiana
University so like I had and I took a
lot of psychology classes and I I was in
the Kinsey building a lot that Kinsey
Institute of whatever psychology and now
they um just recently they put up a
statue of him right outside and so you
know gays against rumors we want to have
a protest down there actually to get
that statue removed because he's sick I
mean he he he experimented sexually on
on babies I think like as young as two
yeah to come up with the Kinsey scale
you know I watched that you ever see the
movie Kinsey with like Liam Neeson or
whatever I think his name is um and it
was like they made him look good he was
the hero obviously you know like he was
good he was the Hollywood hero but it
was a i this was before I knew all this
Insidious stuff about Kinsey
um I loved that movie I I used to rate
myself on the Kinsey scale you know
before I knew all this but basically the
Kinsey scale is that zero you're
completely heterosexual
six you're completely homosexual and
that the idea was like the majority of
the population Falls somewhere in
between not necessarily exactly in the
middle but maybe like a 5.5 or like a
2.3 you know like it's not always so
black and white
but that that's yeah and this was the
father of the sexual Revolution right I
think so yeah him and John money John
money we actually just wrote an article
our um we have a team of writers and we
just put up an article on our site um
gays againstgroomers.com on our blog
about uh John money he is the Godfather
of gender identity and gender theory he
did he he's famous for the David I think
his name is David Reimer
um he basically David was born I think a
hermaphrodite twin boys yeah no they
were twin boys but one of them was a
hermaphrodite no the botched
circumcision oh is that what it was okay
they bought the circumcision and then he
said well here's what we can do you're
right because gender is a social
construct we can raise him as a female
and give him female hormones and he
won't know the difference and he was
never told about this so he was raised
as a girl and he ended up killing
himself in like his 20s both did well no
one died from a drug overdose I think
but like the David I think intentionally
like
yeah I'm reading about Kinsey right now
and I think he was connected to the
Rockefeller foundation and he's also a
eugenicist John money that had these
prepubescent kids simulating sex acts on
each other yeah and then David who I
believe was the the being raised as a
female
rejected the female identity and kept
trying to do boyish things and they kept
desperately trying to force the
socialization of being female but David
kept saying no and then finally the
parents were like okay the depression is
too severe something's wrong here we
have to tell him the truth tell her the
truth and then yeah that whole time
immediately had no idea immediately
detransitioned and said this was wrong
you shouldn't have done this to me I you
know I don't feel that way and then
tried reversing the process eventually
just committed suicide mm-hmm and then
later I think his brother was just so
depressed also and just so messed up
from the whole thing you know because I
don't think he had any idea either that
he ended up dying shortly after but I
believe it was a drug an overdose yeah I
read that yesterday yeah so yeah
eugenicists aren't good people no sorry
go ahead Ian well it's an interesting
debate if sex if if uh sexuality is a
state of mind or if it's something
Society puts on you like the label
what's the what does the label even mean
like who I some people are attracted to
some people like that can change from
day to day like I I get so maybe it's
for money like it can make people money
maybe makes state of like calm state of
mind to think like I am a this therefore
I have some stability in my life yeah I
mean well I think the people always are
looking for like a sense of community or
just to bond with others like them so
maybe I don't know people I feel like
humans in general like putting labels on
themselves and putting things into
categories his brother
yeah so this is the guy John money this
is I mean what you see happening now in
society is like a direct mirror of his
beliefs and his practices right now it's
like transitioning children and just
making up genders on whim and all of
that was his you know that was his thing
and it's being implemented now on a mass
scale and I think Eugenics is the end
game here because when you look at a lot
of these policies when you look at a lot
of these uh kind of social social
cultural changes what does it lead to
people not having babies people not
being able to have babies people over
sexualized so they don't have families
and
um I think that's the key actually I
think like population control I think
that's probably a big aspect too yeah um
that that's you know because killing
people is messy but if you get people to
kill themselves sterilize themselves
yeah that's true I was just talking
about the that new euthanasia like
League lies the euthanasia thing but the
other day but um no I think that the
population control is probably a big big
thing behind it too excuse me and that's
why it's being shoved down everyone's
throat in the culture in the movies and
the series and schools on social media
it's all being promoted and so many
Sinister uh ways where people growing up
especially young children growing up
they're inundated with this oh yeah it's
just non-stop to fit in to be accepted
by The Herd you have to be this and to
have Mainline doctors talk about how
much money they're making off of cutting
off the genitalia of small children yeah
is just absolutely sickening it's
disgusting there's no word really for it
but no I think you know because these
puberty blockers when you put a kid on
puberty blockers it's it's these drugs
the drug Lupron is like the most
um most used puberty blocker for
children huh I said Despicable yeah no
and so it is um routinely for for a very
long time only been used to chemically
castrate sex offenders
um because it that's what it does its
chemical castration drug so what they
are doing they're putting these
prepubescent children on these drugs
which will which is going to sterilize
them they will not be able to have
children later on and they know this
very well you know I don't know the
thing is I don't know if the parents
know this like how can a parent I don't
understand parents are part of this too
like a really big problem as Tim said
they show up to the parking lot of CVS
they're like yeah just put it in me yeah
like I don't know if these doctors are
not making parents aware of the side
effects or well the side effects you
know they're trying to hide the side
effects right now we know for sure that
brain swelling and vision loss are like
two of the big ones from these puberty
blockers as well as sterilization
um and so I just I truly don't
understand how any parent can be on
board with this I think a lot of parents
are like trying to score woke points
somehow especially like these white
liberal women you know they don't know
how else to get woke points
um well a lot of them aren't mentally
stable a lot of them are obese a lot of
them their gut isn't working well and
their brain isn't working well the
father's missing he's not in the home
yeah and
that's so funny I was just going to say
we call you know there's the
transparence of these little kids that
are that want to transition their
children we call them trans housing by
proxy parents or like Munchausen mommies
but we yeah we say trans housing by
proxy because that's exactly what it is
they are using this they're doing this
for themselves to feel good to say oh
look look at me I'm the mommy in the
neighborhood that has a little trans boy
you know like my my three-year-old
daughter is a boy now like they're
they're a bunch of stories about about
like a mom who says all three of my kids
are all trans I've seen I saw that and
it's like what are the odds because it's
like serious uh statistical anomalies
it's it's crazy because like there's
child abuse laws on the books already I
always say this it's like this stuff
needs to fall under that you know like
parents that put their children on these
drugs that that get them hooked up to
the system especially that take them for
surgeries I mean it's it's you know you
guys know Chloe Cole I'm sure she's so
brave I mean what she's doing is
incredible it's saving like an Untold
number of kids yeah
yeah she's the D transitioner who was
put on puberty blockers at 13 and had a
double mastectomy at 15.
um you know meanwhile the the people
that oppose our organization are telling
us every day this isn't happening you
know Jazz Jennings got genital surgery
at 17. yes before the age of 18. yeah so
these things are happening every day I
mean there was a video that came out
from a clinic a hospital in I in
California I forget exactly where but it
was basically they were in a room and
the and they were talking saying how
like the youngest that they've done it
on is a 12 year old girl like a double
mastectomy that's crazy I'm gonna say
these are healthy children and I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna warn people if you
got kids in the room but I I want to say
something about this just as a point of
fact
the purpose of what they refer to as
bottom surgery
for uh male to female transgender
individuals serves one purpose and that
is to create a wound which can be used
to sexually stimulate another individual
so to me
you know thinking about this uh I was
talking with another prominent trans
person uh a few you know you know
because they're they're a handful that
are you know relatively conservative or
at least opposed this stuff and they
mention how they're not interested in
what they call bottom surgery because it
doesn't serve a purpose other than
sexual gratification and it's like a
wound and dilation all these things are
really really severe and there are a lot
of videos of these people of many trans
people who are crying over the the pain
that they're experiencing it's kind of
it's kind of sad but like the the only
purpose for it is to create a hole for
which a a person could insert themselves
into for pleasure and I'm kind of like
I mean that's kind of horrifying to me
to be really honest yeah it's a wound it
is a wound and you know like um the
really horrifying thing I mean that's
very horrifying but even beyond that is
like what they're
um like let's say a child does go on
puberty blockers a boy a biological boy
goes on puberty blockers it stunts their
growth so they will never form a fully
grown penis like it will never grow past
the childhood size of a penis because
they are not going through that happened
to Jazz Jennings okay right and so
that's right
um which caused complications right
because there's not enough there's not
enough skin from the penis to invert to
create a vaginal Canal right right it's
not a vaginal Canal no it's not it's
absolutely not it's a you know mimicking
that it's a creation do they call it a
vaginoplasty yeah they do fugazi but
it's called like uh it's not called the
vaginal Canal no not phalloplasty that's
the other one that's the other one
there's a there's a word for the whole
they create and it's not yeah it's yeah
but no so with you know if
trans
whatever I'm so bad at keeping this
stuff straight but like if there's a
biological boy that wants to be a girl
and he knows very very early on whatever
and the parents put him on puberty
blockers he will never grow to the size
he needs to to create that Neo vagina
um I I think and then they use they use
fish skin they use they're using cadaver
skin now they use like uh the colon it's
just it's you know it's some
Frankenstein stuff you can't play like
humans are not able to play God Like
This truly transhumanist it is not only
is it transgender we have transhumanists
all at the same time the trans agenda of
becoming what we think we are not or
becoming what we think we are what
better way to have people give up their
own humanity and transition into this
larger technocratic system than to of
course get rid of their own identity so
that that you know you made the point
there and I agree with you 100 well the
way the way I described it earlier is
that you're going to be living in a pod
you're going to get a deposit of bugs
into your pod to eat you'll strap up on
your VR headset to go into your virtual
Newsroom and you'll be sitting there
then Godzilla will walk in and sit down
King Kong will walk in and you'll be
early to the meeting and they'll say
well you know before we get the meeting
started anybody catch the game last
night and then King Kong and Godzilla
gonna start arguing over you know who's
gonna be the next draft pick in Virtual
NBA then a carrot's gonna walk in sit
down and back everybody please call him
Dallas get this meeting in order sales
numbers are off the charts and a rabbit
walks in because people are just going
to be alike identify this way this is
what I am yeah and you're going to live
in this virtual reality where people are
just going to be these creatures and
these things I mean you have kids in
school now identifying as animals right
like they had to put a litter box at
once I don't think that's true I think
that was that was not true no there's
there's kids that are identifying as
cats but I don't think I think I think
the litter box things yeah I've never
been able to confirm or deny it but Joe
Rogan I'm pretty sure it came out and
said that he got hoaxed and it wasn't
true but I could be right I don't know
if I heard it first from Joe Rogan it
was it was a meme going around that I've
never seen sourced by anything fair yeah
can I ask you I don't know if you talked
about this before but what made you want
to to do this what got you into this I
don't know if you talked about it before
um no I I not on this scale I don't
think but um
well you know I I have been against kind
of the the direction that Pride Inc that
uh you know lgbtqia Inc has been headed
in a lot for for years now
um I did not agree with the over
sexualization of everything how Pride
fests and parades have basically just
become you know Kink fests like they
just everything is has um swayed so far
from like the original message of when
we were fighting for equality like tree
quality which was a worthy fight it was
a necessary fight but things you know I
I haven't associated with the community
in a very long time and
um when I saw things happening to like
the red line being crossed was going
after kids like I I was not a fan of the
the pushing Pride down everyone's
throats like all the corporations
changing their their um profile pictures
whatever during pride month but then
they started going after kids and me and
a bunch of my friends
um that are also now part of gays
against groomers they we would speak out
against it but there was no Unified
force and I have had a platform called
the gay who strayed for like six years
now which accumulated a large Following
over time and I basically was just like
you know after seeing all of this just
endless stream of these videos coming
out
um of these drag shows for kids and
seeing the material in schools and
seeing that kids are being medicalized
and transitioned I was uh it got to the
point in June where I was just like I
can no longer sit by with this platform
and try and not try and do something to
stop it from the inside so that's you
know the the name came to my head and
the next day I created the account and
put a team together and just got the
ball rolling and it it exploded people
now yeah we have a lot of people is it a
company is it like an incorporation or a
501c3 uh it's a non-profit we have filed
to be a C4
um it takes like six to nine months to
for that process to be approved
um so yeah we're like I said we're
really new we launched in June of this
past year
um so we've done a lot in a short amount
of time and now we have chapters popping
up all over the place
um and it's just it's great to see you
know in the amount of support that we
have is overwhelming I mean we have
haters out there you know like we have
some some pretty loud notable haters uh
that like to call us anti-trans and
anti-lgbtq that's always a funny one you
know Media Matters has written like
eight articles on gays against rumors
now and they always call us an anti an
anti-lgbtq hate group and it's like
that's weird yeah everybody in the
organization is LGB we don't believe in
the queue like we don't believe in the
queue everybody in the organization is
is either LGB or t What Q is queer what
does it mean well queer was always a
slur you know us older gays I mean I'm
not you know just like not these new
gays that are popping up all over the
place you know that was always a slur I
mean people people use that against us
in a very derogatory way and we we um we
tried to get past that but now it's like
they they reclaimed it and rebranded it
and suddenly we're all just supposed to
be okay with it but you know that's the
real slur here we're gonna go to super
chats would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the share with your friends become a
member at timcast.com we're gonna have a
members only show coming up for you
around 11 or so p.m but let's read what
y'all have to say we got this from
flooded timber Farm says Illinois sent
assault weapons ban bill to pritzker
sheriffs denying it across the state
pritzker threatening to fire all that
oppose him yeah they're basically
Banning everything is that what's going
on
the pritzker family is very very bad by
the way in terms of all this trans child
Madness they like fund so much of it all
right on
Jim Bob says yo Ian got your butt gem
y'all sent me the emerald I'm super
stoked bro building a musical Tesla coil
and we'll put it on there so it looks
cool oh nice it's a butt gem wow what it
could be if you wanted it to be it's
just an emerald no questions
Venus Sophia says I have canceled all my
memberships except for my 10 a month to
timcast hope that means something after
supporting you for the last two years
God bless it really really does thank
you so much I really appreciate it a lot
of people are saying this Saturday thing
we're doing is very dangerous
because I'm giving up my assassination
coordinates I think of it as an event
even though it's technically not if you
announce something publicly a time and a
place I feel like it's just de facto and
event and so it should be treated as
such except you can't cancel it
you can't protest it right it's
literally me standing somewhere but for
security purpose is treated as if as
sure sure but like if someone showed up
to protest me standing in a park I would
just walk 10 feet and stand in a
different Park what do you guys I want
to see you do change my mind stuff with
randos that are like he's a Nazi and
you'll be like let's talk
okay we could I mean we'll have cameras
but I'm I'm just I'm just gonna go skate
you know and this guy you know he's
posting saying I couldn't do a shove it
yeah that's a bald-faced lie it's not
true I did a gazelle first try that's a
nollie backside 360 540 shove it okay so
my body does a 360 you're speaking right
now and the board does a five four I did
a first try it's related to Star Wars so
it's like I'll tell you I'll tell you
what he's saying then I'll be fair I
show up I get out of the car I'm riding
my board around and I'm you know sort of
goofing off doing no complies and and
screwing up some flips and shoves
because I'm not really like it's like
such a ridiculous smear to be like Tim
Paul can't do a shove it they're just
lying because they're trying to downplay
the fact that I show up nobody cared
that I was there except for like a
handful of people apparently and I was
better than them at skating and so it's
like they're trying to exert influence
in a community where they have little
except for the fact that people are
scared they'll get canceled if they
speak out against them or something like
that right so I'm like okay well I'll
show up I'll skate plus they're also
claiming that people brought me there
and that's the weirdest stupid thing
ever I showed up with Allison it was
like me and her and we're by our elves
and I'm skating around and there's some
guy that I knew that I talked to and now
they're trying to claim that someone
else told like someone else brought me
there I'm like what are you talking
about dude like I'm the one who's like
hey guys you want to go skate here I
showed up by myself they're just making
things up because they're crackpot
weirdos but if they want to make up
crackpot weird stuff I'm gonna show it
and my point is this uh for those who
are who are giving the 10 bucks a month
I mean it when I say I stand up for what
I believe in and people often say like
oh you don't know how hard it is and
like I can't do it for this reason or
that reason and I'm like okay well if
you think being swatted 15 times
multiple death threats and the bomb
squad hung up twice is enough for me to
hide and move to the middle of nowhere
like some other personalities have done
fine just know that I have announced
where I will be Saturday morning DC's
Freedom Plaza and I'll be skating around
you know be hanging out yeah and we're
going to bring the crew Phil Labonte is
going to be there a handful of other
people are planning on be there I'm
gonna bring a whole bunch of people
Taylor Silverman's gonna be there that
should be fun you know and we'll skate
and that's it reminds me of the days of
the YouTube meetups the live meetups
where we'd all go to New York Washington
Square Park on July 7th 2007 and
everybody's there with their cameras and
Taylor is Awesome by the way shouts out
to Taylor that was cool and there's like
there's nothing you say it's like an
event like maybe but there's nothing to
protest if people shut up protesting I'd
be like I will stand there instead like
there's no tent there's no speakers
there's no speeches there's just yo if
people are there and it's crowded I will
walk 20 feet and skate across the street
I will tell everybody okay let's go to
the other skate park yeah we're going to
be walking around if they want to follow
us around but I have a feeling like I
don't think anything's gonna happen I
think the point of this is to show
people that all of this hype around like
oh no people are mad you can't go
nothing's gonna happen something's gonna
happen lollipop shove at 7 20 in your
face not a real trick okay well it
sounds as real as the others you could
say Ali Lake 720 shove it which would be
absolutely bonkers but uh that would
just like you'd have to launch off a
ramp or a big drop or something like
that maybe or a half-life but no
probably not even but um what will
likely happen is fans of the show will
show up we'll give out a bunch of boards
from the back of the car and uh we'll
skate and uh Phil will be singing Ian
will be jamming Carter will be jamming
if he gets up yeah he wants it's a 10
a.m thing though I don't know
yeah that sounds fun I wake up at seven
that's when Ian goes to sleep that's
right she is last night I got to bed at
like 6 a.m but look look my point is
this everybody's like I'm getting
messages from people being like dude are
you serious about this like you better
be careful I'm like dude I'm telling you
I'm gonna show up and nothing's gonna
happen yeah like first of all I'm not
that important there's not good like
nothing's gonna happen stop being afraid
of these people nothing will happen the
only thing that's gonna happen our fans
are fans are going to show up that's the
way I feel honestly you know people
people kind of think I'm a little crazy
I'm like these people they're not gonna
you know honestly we get like it's kind
of interesting how many death threats we
get not to you know override you here
but it you know people say this stuff
and in your case they have done stuff
you know they have tried it's it's all
it's all like making the police do it
because they're too scared right yeah
these people are very scary you know
they're scared of their own shadow they
just talk big talk and but it all but at
the same time it only just takes one
crazy person right sure but I don't
think that you can let that run your
life I think as a model when you set up
when you use social media to set times
and days for people to meet that you
have a responsibility to protect those
people at least to the best of your
ability with security yes wide open
space like I look at John Kennedy man
that guy was the presidents don't go out
open and ride around in the city anymore
because I agree when it's you know when
there's more people than just yourself
you have to worry about but I I don't
think I think it's okay I walk around
all the time all this is what they've
tweeted they've tweeted like Tim Poole
should live in fear Matt Walsh lives of
tick tock should live in fear and never
have a moment of Peace again and I'm
like bro I have no idea what you're
talking about I go walk around I was I
was by myself in DC's Freedom plot and
apparently some people were hanging back
and texting about how angry they are
they were that I was there and not a
single person said anything other than
me other to me than other than fist
bumping me one of the OG local guys some
old black dude walked up and gave me a
fist bump was like what up brother
what's going on and one other dude was
doing tricks we like talked for a little
bit they they make this stuff up I walk
around all the time and have no problems
I'm not worried about it all right let's
read some more 1776's life says enjoying
the episode dinner tonight Garden raised
vegetables with venison hunted this year
Tim can we work on a podcast about
procuring cooking nutritious food I
would be willing to assist we wanted to
do a homesteading and like survivalist
show that'd be really fun
something cool like almost like you ever
guys ever watch Ancient technology oh
yeah that channel where it's like you
know yes sorry I just got really excited
that's the one like I watched all the
time when I was obsessed with my bushes
it's so good he's amazing how do you do
that stuff it's amazing it's cool
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim your
Healthy Life message is an important one
we can't be fatties fighting for our
nation taking breaks to catch our breath
the cult will not wait for us to catch
up we must prepare ourselves
yeah it's very exciting man that's right
all right this was a good one we got
this from the real Hydro PX yeah Hydro
you know me love him he says do not
allow people like Luke to keep saying
Biden is forgetful Luke is working for
the Deep State no gaslighting Luke
hold on I gotta I gotta see what the CIA
tells me to respond to with this one uh
okay that's a good opinion you have
there I like it because like when Rick
has to see I could muster Reagan was
like I don't remember all the things
you're accusing me of I don't remember
because Alzheimer's like now dude you
gotta take responsibility for your
actions I don't care where your mind's
at I believe the president's a puppet
most presidents are
oh yeah Nick ossify says need a
recommendation I love rollerblading and
skating but broke my ankle and now my
foot sits crooked where can I find a
high-end pair of custom skates so I can
skate comfortably once again
honestly I have no idea custom skates
are a really difficult thing to do
unless you can like 3D print something
it's hard enough to get real blades
these days because the industry
basically doesn't exist I mean look
skateboarding is a crippled industry
it's just like it does not it there's
wealthy skateboarders but they do not
make that much money yeah let alone the
blading industry they bear the blading
industry barely exists
[Music]
pinochet's helicopter tour says Luke
please stop making excuses for Biden
Occam's razor man he is pretending to be
senile but knows exactly what he is
doing it's all by Design I don't think
he's calling the shots here no that's
just my distance here imagine and we
talked about that we talked about
different uh possibilities here and I
entertained that possibility as well but
I'm more convinced that there's a bigger
power at play here yeah Biden he he's
like walking around his hands like Mr
Burns and he's larger and then the
camera turns off and he stands up
straight straight to Stein says let's
get to work right or they just have a
bunch of Biden actors that they give the
script to read and then they're like
okay this one's out this one's uh past
its expiration date bring in Biden
number xz5 and that's and that's
probably what happened a lot of people
covered variant 1.5 I know it's from the
Jimmy Fallon
good we got to go in here from Brett
Bullard he says Jamie why doesn't the
gay community draw the line at LGB how
are the traditionalist religious Etc
expected to accept the alphabet
Community as they become increasingly
anti-straight
right um well I I've spoken about this
before me personally I never thought
that LGB and T should have been combined
together
um way back when when they were
um I you know being LGB is about who you
love being T being trans is about who
you are or who you believe you are I I
have said I have more in common with a
straight man than I do a trans person I
just don't have any shared anything with
them you know honestly and so I've never
understood why they were lumped together
um I do want to say that like you know
there is the trans Mafia like there are
these radical trans activists who have
become like the
talking head that that is like the
position of all trans people and it's
really not you know like the trans
people I know and the people that we
have the trans people we have engaged
against groomers and in trans against
groomers like they are good people they
just want to live their lives like just
like we do and these people are giving
them a really bad name
um it is always the activists and The
Fringe you know radicals that destroy
everything for everybody and that that's
true about any group of people you know
like um and so that they they want to
fight this just as hard as we do and
that you know I created trans against
rumors which is like a subsect a partner
of gays against rumors because so many
trans people were reaching out agreeing
with what we're doing at gaze against
groomers and wanting to help somehow you
know so I we made their own little uh
group for them and they're doing their
thing with us um and so I I really think
their voices are very important I agree
that LGB and T are very different things
but um I I would encourage people to not
base their ideas on every you know all
trans people as a whole on on the
messaging you see coming from like trans
Inc and just the alphabet Mafia in
general because that that people you
know the backlash against gay people is
growing right now too because whatever
you see happening this this push on
children you know people assume that all
gay people are on board with this and
support this one that's very far from
reality and that's why gays against
groomers is so important to to show that
right on Pizza Steve says do a cow show
like chicken City and call it the steak
whole Elders haha well we're planning on
getting one cow but apparently they
produce 10 to 12 gallons of milk per day
yeah wow wow that's what about the
little ones you look at those mini cows
mini cows like a pygmy cows or something
you see those maybe we'll get some goats
yeah do you mean cows we need a cow just
don't ever end up in the Logan Paul
situation dude his Pig you heard about
that yeah he a beaut well I don't know
apparently it wasn't he gave it I mean
we can get into this if you want other
ways we can pass but but yeah that's a
quick version okay he he uh when he was
moving to Puerto Rico he couldn't take
his Pig Pearl bing bing I think was the
name and uh so he gave it to this um
Farm where that they said they were
going to take care of it her the pig and
um but then they ended up giving it to
somebody else who totally neglected it
left it alone to die basically in a
field that was found by these people
called The Gentle Farm who then adopted
Pearl and are taken care of her now but
so apparently you know Logan didn't have
a hand in that in abandoning her like he
did think he was providing a good home
but then like you know it just ended up
that way yeah Logan says and I'm not
here to defend them the Matrix attacked
him oh yeah that was funny that was
funny ready for a wave of people that
are blaming their misfortunes on The
Matrix that damn Matrix is it not oh
all right mazaro says hey Tim and crew
today is my 33rd birthday can I get a
shout out also Ian I appreciate your
opinions on the topics keep rolling them
20s oh you gotta be happy birthday
mizero yeah happy birthday mazaro and
and stop encouraging Ian
Drew outstanding in his field says first
you get the chickens then you get the
eggs then you get the freedom Luke's
Scarface tweet see you at Freedom Plaza
Scarface what I I didn't get that one
Luke's oh yeah I posted it I posted it I
posted it no no I posted a Scarface uh
meme of uh instead of Scarface sitting
in front of all the cocaine he was
sitting up with a bunch of egg cartons
around him because the price of eggs has
pretty much doubled nice oh this is
funny uh
kaiju's spirit says pilot friend said
FAA crashed due to change in no Tam
definition notice to Airmen
became notice to air Mission it's a
rumor but see the problem men oh my God
if that is true
I wouldn't be surprised if it was but
I'm kind of like I don't know about that
maybe basically like they went in the
computer and said notice to Airmen and
changed it to air Mission because
the the roots to like break was it based
on training well no it's because
misogyny misogyny it's patriarchy or
whatever well shouldn't it yeah there
you go we're all men human
then we're women and men on top of that
let me
here Steve says no Tam is was noticed to
air men
they changed it they're now saying uh
they tweeted that it was noticed to air
mission
do you guys think it's okay to call
everybody guys because I just yeah yeah
hey guys dudes
hey man what's going on man are you
trying to apologize for calling People
guys dude well my whole life I call
these two women guys when I was waiting
tables when I was 18 or something yeah
you say hey guys I am not a guy and they
left me a nickel is a tip just to let me
know that they it wasn't like they
didn't forget Survivor had a very cringe
uh moment where the host was asking the
the new people there hey can I say guys
is that okay and everyone's like yeah
it's totally cool it's fine and then
like two episodes down there someone was
thinking about it like no it's not okay
it's offensive you need to stop and then
he stopped and he capitulated and went
on his knees and then sacrificed his
soul and dignity on live National
Television all right sorry Jeff I say
Federalists all of you are correct and
stakeholder capitalism being chi-com
control same as the Greenies have been
called watermelons Forever Green on the
outside Kami on the inside like beef
roast brown shirts in World War II
Fabian socialists go slow but I wonder
if it's chi-com control or if
something's controlling chi-com and
they're using CCP tactics I don't know
because I definitely don't think the CCP
is running the show like there is flimsy
no but it's government right now
politicians went to China saw what they
were doing and said hey you get the
benefits of absolute dictatorship with
the benefits of a capitalist system you
just got to control the capitalist
system so that they can work only
underneath your dictatorship no no the
politicians went there and then set up
that system and now they're testing how
far they could get away with it so yeah
like a bunch of politicians in what was
it the 70s or 80s Henry Kissinger David
Rockefeller
um and uh I think it was Nixon yeah yep
they opened up China it was the open
China policy that sent all of our jobs
and all of our factories over there and
basically for slave labor basically the
Soviet Union communism doesn't work sen
command economies don't work how can you
have a capitalist economy that exists
only as a subset of a command economic
system meaning people have Mobility at
the bottom but you have 10 drills in
every single business that rises to a
certain level so if somebody owns a
pizza restaurant you don't care but if
they now have a hundred pizza
restaurants you get an office in their
corporate headquarters and can control
what they say and do yeah you get a
monopoly on the market and the first
thing that Western politicians did in
China was Implement a one-child policy
which was absolutely destructive and and
is leading to so much tremendous human
suffering and harm that we can't even
imagine we uh the Wizards of the Coast
is prompting to change their licensing
things so if you use Dungeons and
Dragons and you make a game show if you
make over seven or fifty thousand
dollars a year they take 20 of
everything you make from now on they're
retroactively or at least is what I
heard from Phil DeFranco undoing the old
contract even the old contract said we
can never change this free contract now
they're like the new contract overrides
that let's make a new one like yeah make
new game you know Eric July has got
ripaversed let's make DND was always
just the easiest one to use it was never
the best so so let's just make
a nearly identical structure with
different formatting or something or
like I mean themes yeah we'll call it
d10 instead of d20s instead of Dungeons
and Dragons we'll call it castles and
kings
you want to play castles and Kings like
yeah sure okay I'm an elf you're a dwar
that's going to start happening
unfortunately because Blizzard or uh
wizard of the coast rather not blizzard
um is obsessively trying to control them
they got rid of races
in dungeons yeah they got rid of racial
bonuses I heard is that real did that
really happen I'm pretty sure and like
because now it doesn't matter but it
used to be like if you were an elf you
had a certain bonus if you were a human
but they're like oh that sounds racist
to me
okay well let's just make our own yeah I
think I brought it up one because I
wanted to talk about it but two because
it's like top down control of the like
they're trying to undo contracts what
how so contracts mean nothing mean
nothing if that if they're able to do
that all right you just got to make your
own thing you know very calm you know
and you know we'll do we'll use the
physical spaces we set up to host events
to promote these parallels you know I
think about Seth MacFarlane creating the
Orville because Star Trek got woke and
went broke and so even though Seth
MacFarlane is not like anti-work or
anything he made the Orville which was
more similar to the Next Generation in
Star Trek because he wanted to maintain
that that certain level and they
actually had some pretty based episodes
like the one where the girls the baby's
forced under a sexual transition have
you seen this the Orville no there's an
episode where there's a planet where
there's only men so when they give when
they an egg hatches into female they're
like it must be made into a male through
transition and then they do and then
when the kid grows it gets older it's
the kid's like I don't want to be a boy
I want to be a girl this is wrong and so
they de-transition the kid and I'm I'm
like that's pretty based it's not like a
definitively anti-trans or pro-trans
statement that just explored the idea in
a way that I was like I was surprised by
but uh that Seth macfarland basically
saying like I'm gonna do my thing and
it's you know it's Star Trek the Orville
it's literally Star Trek the union the
Federation he just copied it so that's
what we'll do we'll make our own version
that's what needs to happen tabletop RPG
called castles and Kings across Linden
Kings yeah it's so easy it's so easy
that name Crosslands Crosslands yeah how
about that the Crosslands call it rage
and then we'll use rage as a is like a
thing you get your all characters can
build up their rage and use it as like I
think we should call it the Crosslands
and that's like I can't stop you that
that's the basis for the universe it's
like where the different realities the
Crosslands that'll be like the um the
different planes of reality it's the
it's the it's the Nexus point of all the
different planes into the Cross Plains
the Crosslands cross planes we'll go
there the cross line let's do it and
then uh if somebody wants to help craft
the tabletop RPG called the Crosslands
where there's the Crosslands can be in
the game you can go there no but it
doesn't have to be the name of it I
think it's a good name really because
like within the game then you can go to
like any Universe you go is based on you
travel through the CrossFit like from
the Crosslands into yeah man boom which
is exactly times time I like guns and
planes the Crosslands and they'll make a
card game for it where there's like four
elements and they're and you draw the
cards and you play the elements to to
cast spells that you pull from the
Crosslands to something pretty cool yeah
you've got at least four you got like
nine because there could be nine
different planes lands I guess we could
call them
roads maybe they're all roads like you
never actually get there you only go
towards it and you always head towards
it six colors
let's write this down all right and then
we basically replace d d and uh Magic
the Gathering uh one move all right and
then we'll buy Wizards
the revenues Drifter says I've been
paying attention to him longtime viewer
what's the deal with skating in DC be
careful man the deal is
um we go skating quite a bit we went to
the opening of the Hagerstown skate park
it was a big crowd there it was a lot of
fun a bunch of people came up and gave
us fist bumps we had a picnic it was
delicious I had uh we had like beef with
uh with havarti and some mustard on it
and uh we skated and there was not a
single issue I go to the DC skate park
and now there's this weird conspiracy
that like some Pro Skater Pro skaters
like told like brought me with them or
something and that everyone was was
hiding on the other side of the park
away from me and that I couldn't pop
shove it or something and I'm like I
literally just shut up to a plaza and
skated around and like talked to some
random people and it became such like
this this big deal I guess they're
posting on in forums that I was like
okay I'm going back like dude we're
gonna go skate we're gonna have fun and
that's the point I'm not gonna let
people make up lies and try and chase us
out of spaces when literally nothing
happened so my view is
there should be no issue I'll show up
we'll skate we'll hang out we'll do like
a cool little meet and greet kind of
thing
Phil Labonte If All That Remains is
going to be there uh Ian's gonna be
there because we're gonna make him get
up early enough he's gonna be playing
guitar oh my God big crowds everyone's
gonna be cheering and 11 A.M are you
kidding me no 11 A.M
12 noon right jeez I say 12. I want you
to just to think Ian people are gonna be
like
yeah yeah and you're gonna be playing
the guitar Phil's going to be singing
and everyone's gonna be wow and the
police are going to be like this Ian
guy's too popular we gotta shut this
down but I like it but I like it dancing
yeah all right
Let's uh let's grab another one Jason
says uh yatin build a wood fire pizza
oven they are great and you can cook
More Than Just Pizza in them done
we actually were trying we're gonna do
it here we actually had a plan for
creating a wood fire oven and then we
decided not to do it because we're doing
all the new construction at freedomastan
but we'll do a a brick wood fire oven
what is this new place called
freedomastan
Luke came up with it I think Luke
randomly called it that yeah like as a
joke it sticks right right down the
stand people are like free dominant yeah
Freedom right see I heard the Dom I'm
like is this a play on I hope it's not
no no yeah no but then I get it it takes
a second I think you'll call it freedom
of Stan or Freedom stand predominant and
then I was like for the you know free
Domin stand because you put the eye in
there yeah yeah Freedom estan it works
it's better than free to stand
definitely like Freda Stan isn't an
option rather than slavistan you don't
want that free town called New York City
slavistan Andre garisamenco says Tim
it's not our fault you are gas stove
deficient in 40 Years of cooking I've
never burnt bacon on the stove oven yes
I went to an Airbnb and they had a gas
stove and I grew up with a gas stove and
I got no problem with it and there was a
vent in the other room that was blowing
and so the the flame kept going like
this that sucks and then I had to move
the pan over to the left to get it to
cook evenly I'm like if this is just
electric like we have here it would have
evenly lit the whole thing up way faster
and cooked my bacon way faster I'm not a
chef I'm not sitting here trying to do
flame techniques I'm just trying to cook
bacon quickly environment is important
if you have too much of a breeze flame
is almost useless yeah you gotta close
the window turn the fan off because the
Flames bouncing around uh get out of
here yeah no I totally agree with that
point but I still don't think you should
be forced we should be able to have our
gas stoves I agree yeah we should put
them with plasma yeah I might just go
get one just in spite of all this
honestly Joseph I want one Joseph says
how fast all women wore yoga pants blows
my mind
just in general it's just Trends yeah I
was there for that Trend in L.A all of a
sudden everybody's wearing yoga pants in
2008. it's like not wearing pants at all
yeah it's really bad when they wear like
nude colored ones like beige ones like
generally like from like a few feet away
it looks like like you're just wearing
there's also a theory that there's a lot
of plastic in them and a lot of very bad
chemicals that are really bad for a
women's reproductive I'm sure that's
absolutely true in the pants yep really
yeah I just got a yoga mat but I went
all the way to the top really I got the
best how much was it 130 bucks not all
the way but way better than those cheap
thirty dollar mats I don't want that
potassium bromate yeah plastic is
leachable is that are you here what is
this
there's a rumor going around someone
said this
Adam drop says Andrew Tate has become an
idol because they've torn down all our
others as they are seen as toxic like
Elliot page possibly Superman come on
man so I Googled that there are a bunch
of stories saying Elliot page may
replace Henry Cavill as Superman yeah
please please say something let's do it
I want the bat girl movie I want it to
come out let it all be let it all fall
on its face
I totally agree with that part about
Andrew Tate though you know this whole
toxic masculinity movement degrading you
know men for being men and and shunning
them has led to this you know really
stupid Idols let's let's take advantage
of these people I want to talk about
this we'll pull the article for the
members only segment so smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the share with your friends become a
member at timcast.com for the uncensored
segment which will be up in about an
hour where we'll carry on that
conversation I want to talk about that
one that that matters toxic masculinity
and all this stuff you can uh follow the
show at timcast IRL basically everywhere
follow us on Instagram right now you can
follow me personally at timcast but more
importantly follow at timcast news on
Twitter Jamie you want to shout anything
out uh yeah if you want to learn more
about gays against groomers please go to
gaze againstgroomers.com everything
about us there are ways to support us
too uh all of our socials as well but we
are most active on Twitter and Instagram
Twitter is against
grmrs that's when we had to avoid the
word groomer back in the pre-ylon days
and then uh Instagram is just gays
against groomers so appreciate that
thank you and you're an OG Ron pauler I
am an OG Ron pauler yeah we bonded over
that yeah awesome well thank you so much
yeah thank you so much for coming out
you're awesome uh my website is Luke
uncensored.com and there's a lot of
things that I'm doing on there I'm doing
an AMA on there right now I just
released a video about Neil degrice
Tyson going crazy and freaking out that
video is going to be available for free
for everyone this Friday if you are on
our email list right now it's available
for members sign up on the email list
very easily on we are change.org you
again so much for having me I really
appreciate the ever flowing font of
inspiration I received from you
listening and responding and interacting
with the show and with me and all over
social media if you want to get in touch
more at Ian Crossland hit me up anywhere
very happy to see you good to see Jim
thanks
hey y'all uh it is me in the comments
it's at surge.com I do respond I do read
everyone's statements uh I think it's
like something I can do to contribute to
the show uh I thought this was a good
one I've been a fan for a while it's
been nice to meet you in real life yeah
no worries that means a lot hey cool and
uh yeah check it next time become a
member Tim cast love it guys we will see
you all over at timcast.com let's talk
about Elliot Pages Superman thanks for
hanging out oh geez